hey everyone it is Friday 3 p.m. you
know what that means it's the start of a
marathon live discussion Q&A whatever
focusing on whatever you'd like to talk
about in the world I tend to focus upon
things like quantum mechanics and
relativity and unified theories and so
on but I'm open to questions on just
about anything if I don't know the
answer I will tell you straight out I'm
not a bag of hot air that pontificates
on every subject regardless of what it
is I'm only going to talk about things
that I feel I understand or at least
have thought deeply about you may
disagree with my perspective on things
but I will not spout off on things that
I haven't thought about so let's just
get right into it and bring up the live
chat actually saw something on on
YouTube that I thought was a good
question maybe to begin with oh yeah so
so born to stew song too soon sorry
point you soon okay I get it I'm a
little thick could you please explain
maybe in the next Q&A session what
underlies the information paradox of
black holes and yeah we did have an
episode you didn't need to watch it on
black holes it was the last one I think
that I did was a few days ago now as now
your daily equation has turned into your
every other day daily equation or every
third day sorry I've just got a lot
going on at the moment but there is a
puzzle about black holes which is we all
know the image that you have a black
hole region of space which it has an
event horizon surrounding it and
according to the classical equations and
the general theory of relativity if you
cross over the edge of the event horizon
of black low you can't get out and that
that would be that now Stephen Hawking
changed that picture in a way that I
should have an episode on which I
haven't done yet Hawking showed that
when you include quantum mechanics not
just our insides classical description
of gravity I mean you could quantum
mechanics to stuff can get out of a
black hole
he found that black holes radiate
now he found that they radiate thermal
radiation was I mean that's just heat
heat that doesn't have any information
content just the random motion of
particles emanating from the surface of
a black hole and indeed according to
these ideas as the black hole radiates
it gets smaller just like when charcoal
burns a black piece of charcoal as it
burns it gets smaller as it's giving off
radiation you know that from your your
barbecue the same thing happens with a
black hole and therefore if you wait
long enough very very long timescales
black holes themselves will evaporate
now that's very very interesting that's
very interesting because imagine you
throw something into a black hole I
don't care what it is your iPhone your
wallet a picture and encyclopedia
whatever that entity carries information
not only can have actual information
like you know phone numbers or the data
in an encyclopedia but it has
information just by virtue of the
relationships between the particles
making up the structure it's an
organized orderly structure it has
information it falls in now the question
is as the black hole radiates and
evaporates does the information that
fell into a black hole does it get back
out and that's a very important question
that people have struggled with because
if the information does not come back
out then there's a loss of information
and when you carefully look at the
equation say of quantum mechanics a loss
of information ruins our perspective on
how the universe evolves over time if
information can truly get lost
think about that means you don't have
the ability to make predictions about
the future because predicting the future
requires a complete understanding of the
state of the universe in the past but if
information gets lost then that complete
description will elude you so people
were very disturbed about this
possibility of a loss of information and
it took 20-30 years before consensus
really began to come together that
information is not lost inside
of a black hole at first Stephen Hawking
said famously information is lost he
said it quite poetically I won't be able
to reproduce exactly the language that
he used but something like as
information falls into a black hole it
gets lost within the folds of space-time
gone even Stephen Hawking ultimately
changed his mind and came to the
conclusion that the information would
come back and that's that's where things
stood say till a few years ago until
another puzzle came up and that puzzle
is that if information really does come
out of a black holes most people think
then there is a tension with the edge of
the black hole being an ordinary point
in space in the sense of there's no
signpost there's no singularity there
you fall over the edge you won't even
know it according to classical general
theory of relativity and the reason for
that is a little bit involved it has to
do with entanglement particles that are
entangled across the horizon versus
particles outside the horizon that are
entangled with each other and thereby
carrying information you can't have
those kind of triple entangled States
it's called the monogamy of entanglement
entanglement is not polygamists you
can't have three particles maximally
entangled with one another and that
winds up giving the possibility that the
entanglement across the horizon is
broken if that's true energy would be
released by that breaking of
entanglement which might yield a
firewall a region of incredibly hot
thermal density on the edge of a black
hole which would burn up anything that
tried to fall in which might mean there
isn't even an inside to a black hole it
could be that space-time itself ends at
the event horizon if these firewall
ideas are correct so anyway that's that
those are the kind of puzzles that
people are still struggling with but you
see that it's a ongoing story that
reaches all the way back to the early
ideas of black holes and on to some of
the most cutting-edge insights into the
nature of quantum mechanics in the edge
of a black hole so thank you for that
question it is a good one obviously a
subtle one
what else do we have her so so professor
green Tsai asks my question is following
why is it that physicists only talk
about the frequency and wavelength of
the photon and not of the electron or
the quark and it's not completely true
when when we talk about the wave
function of an electron we really do use
that language of wavelengths and
frequencies the reason why you perhaps
are more familiar with that language for
photons is because photons being a
particle of light the language of light
is in terms of wavelengths and
frequencies from the get-go whereas the
language of electrons from the get-go is
more energy and momentum but according
to quantum mechanics there is a
dictionary between the energy of a
particle and its frequency and between
the momentum of a particle and its
wavelengths and we do use that language
for electrons maybe not with as much
intensity or as often I don't want to
say it's frequently then I'm gonna make
use of the language of the question but
we do we do use that language for
electrons and quarks just as we use it
for photons moses tec / asks professor
green can quantum entanglement be used
to transport data faster than the speed
of light and that's an essential
question and the answer is no as far as
we know you might think that it could be
used because after all if you've got two
particles at distant locations and if
you do something over here at
instantaneously affects something over
there well there it is instantaneous
influence but when you think about it
there's no information in this process
because if you're an observer over here
at my right hand and another one of you
in this chat is an observer at my left
hand if you have a whole collection of
entangled particles you know spinning up
and spinning down and you measure them
one after another after an
they're at my right hand if you look at
the set of data it'll be something like
up up down up down down down up up down
it'll be a random sequence of up and
downs if the particles are in a 50/50
mixture of up and down the set of data
at my left hand that you accumulate will
also be a random collection down up down
down up up up down and so forth the only
interesting thing is that these two
random collections of results are
correlated when this one is up this
one's down when this one's down this one
is up and so forth but you'd only ever
recognize that correlation when you
compare the random output at each
location and that comparison is a slower
than light process you got to bring the
information together you got to get on
your cell phone you got to communicate
so there's a classical channel that has
to be brought to bear or I should really
say a slower than light channel let me
not use that language a slower than
light speed channel needs to be brought
to bear to even recognize that there is
a correlation in the data but over here
person over here right person random
data left person ran with no information
information is only there through the
correlations they can only be gleaned
discern ascertained by a slower than
light process
okay let me see what else we have here
[Music]
how does the graviton hackers lab asks
how does the graviton theoretically
mediate gravity and it's a question I'm
frequently asked because you know when
we talk about gravity in the general
theory of relativity we talk about warps
and curves in space and we imagine that
objects are guided by these grooves in
the space-time fabric in Einstein's
theory that's how we talk about the
force of gravity in Newton's theory we
just talk about action at a distance one
mass here another mass there and they
pull on each other without specifying
how that pull is actually accomplished
so you might say where do gravitons get
in on the story and roughly speaking
they get in on the story as the
transmitter of gravity so when we talk
about mass one and mass two pulling on
each other you can think about that as
the exchange of these little particles
these little gravitons and these
so-called messenger particles these
force particles these force carrying
particles carry and instruction when you
receive this particle move a little bit
closer to the source and so forth and
that's where the gravitational tug comes
from in the language of gravitons what
about the warps encouragin space-time
how do you relate that to gravitons and
the analogy not really analogy theme I
guess it is an analogy it's not a it's a
scientific analogy is really with light
waves and photons when you think about a
beam of light as an oscillating
electromagnetic wave that's one language
when you think of a beam of light as a
stream of photons little pockets little
pellets of light little bundles of light
that's another language how do these
languages relate to each other well if
you have enough photons moving in the
right choreographed manner they can fill
out a wave-like shape much as h2o
molecules
and the ocean can fill out waterways
water is made of particles h2o molecules
and yet we know what a water wave is
it's when a lot of those h2o molecules
move in the appropriate choreographed
manner similarly a light wave is photons
whose motions are choreographed
correctly and therefore if you want to
talk about warps and curves in space
from gravity same idea gravitons that
are arranged moving in the right
choreographed manner fill out the warps
and curves in the general theory of
relativity so that's the the rough
language more precise languages use
coherent States it's a way of
approximating classical descriptions
using quantum formalism but in terms of
a visualization of what's going on
that's a that's a good way of thinking
about it so Allie unis son asks why is
it the case if you add up all the
natural numbers you get minus 1/12 and I
wish I can answer that quickly I have
been meaning to do an episode on that
it's a little bit involved but the
bottom line is when you have divergent
sums so obviously one plus two plus
three plus four plus five you keep on
going it's divergent it goes to infinity
right but when you have divergent sums
we like to play an interesting game
which is to find functions that are well
defined that are not blown up to
infinity and yet if we change a
parameter in that function for a special
choice of the parameter the function is
equal to 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5
so it's a way of so-called regulating
the sum to make it finite by virtue of
seeing that sum as a special case of a
general function whose properties are
better behaved than the divergent sum
itself and you can do that with a
so-called Riemann zeta function if you
take the zeta
function which I think as many of you
know is can be written as a divest
summation 1 over N to the s when s
equals with negative 1 then you're
adding up the natural numbers and when
you look at the Riemann zeta-function
behavior as s approaches minus 1 indeed
the value approaches minus 1/12 so
that's how that comes about but it's
less mysterious than a thing then you
would think it's not literally case if
you sort of added one post to persuade
before and just go up to infinity that
it's minus or twelve at the end it's not
sort of somehow it's minus 1/12 in any
sense that sort of the the finite sums
get larger and larger then somehow turn
over and head down towards zero then
cross here and go to minus 1/12 it's
rather a way of defining what that sum
means in a manner that's mathematically
well-behaved and when you do that you're
in essence redefining the sum to be the
value of this function at a special
location which in the case I just
described gives the sum of the natural
numbers to be minus or twelve pride asks
hi Brian thanks for doing this I was
wondering if you're willing to provide
your view on the twin paradox of
relativity there seems to be some
inconsistency regarding the how and the
why I wish I knew what you had in mind
pride and you can feel free to fill that
in I guess in a subsequent post I'm not
aware of any inconsistency whatsoever
in the twin paradox at all so again what
is a twin paradox imagine I have a twin
and that twin steps into a rocket ship
goes out into space turns around and
comes back and traveled really quickly
according to relativity when my twin
gets out of the ship my twin will be
younger than I am less time will have
elapsed for my twin than for me and we
understand this perfectly well in the
theory of relativity theory of special
relativity the basic asymmetry I mean
the whole puzzle is you it seems
completely symmetric I'm watching my
twin go
a ship but my twin could be looking back
at earth and from my twins perspective
I am the earth I'm heading that way and
then we turn around and we come back and
we join up with the twin so it seems to
be all a matter of perspective motions
relative and from my perspective the
twin is going off into space but from my
twins perspective I'm the one who's
going off into space so how could there
be an asymmetry in the ages of the two
individuals when they rejoin if the
situation seems to be completely
symmetric answer it's not completely
symmetric only one member of this pair
experiences an acceleration when I am
being viewed by my twin from the rocket
ship my twin sees me go off into space
on the earth and then come back I don't
experience an acceleration because I
don't actually turn around and come back
it's is mother twin who slows down the
engines on the rocket ship turns around
and comes back it is the twin that
experiences that slow down and speed up
it is the twin that experiences the
acceleration that breaks the symmetry
and we look at that in detail you find
it ensures that the twin who is in the
ship will be the one who's younger now
if you want to see that in great detail
somebody asked this on the previous chat
but if you want to see that in great
detail go to world science u.com I don't
think it's live now or maybe live or
it's it's being revamped I think it's
coming out in roughly a week so if you
can wait a week go to my special
relativity course on world science you
and toward the end it's free right no
money so it's free and you go to the end
of that course and I have three modules
on the twin paradox one explains it as I
just did but the others explain it in
more visual ways asking the question
what if you had an infinitely powerful
telescope you and your twin both of
infinitely powerful telescope and you're
watching each other during the space
journey so you can literally sort of see
what's going on through your telescope
what will each of you see one of you
needs to see the other getting older
faster then you're getting older in
order for there to be an asymmetry
in the two ages and so I go through that
both visually and mathematically and I
find it very helpful to go through these
other explanations because it really
nails down what it is that's going on so
I would suggest you take a look at that
pride and I think you'll find it
enlightening but if not you should feel
free to ask again here or at a
subsequent one of these sessions Luca
says hi Brian could you please say Luca
you are the best for my fiance to hear
what do you think the next big discovery
in theoretical physics is and then it
raced away so I but I think I got to the
end oh and the the great next great
discovery in theoretical physics Luca so
Luca I I don't know but I can make a
guess that the next major discovery by
which I will take it to me in a
revolutionary discovery that in the
future scientists look back on as one of
those critical moments of advancement in
understanding I think it's going to
happen when we finally gain true insight
into the fundamental makeup of space and
time we've done very well in
understanding the fundamental makeup of
matter right there was a time when
people didn't even believe in atoms but
you know by the early years of the 20th
century it became very clear that atoms
were real and then subsequent
discoveries that were all familiar with
from school we learned about the
neutrons to protons a nucleus the
electrons in orbit quantum orbits around
the nucleus the quarks inside the
neutrons and protons and so on so we've
done a really good job at understanding
the ingredients that make up matter what
about the possibility of ingredients
that make up space and time are there
any does that
should make sense if there are atoms of
space and time how must they be put
together to yield space and time as we
experience those features of the world
and once we can gain headway on these
questions
a truly quantum mechanical particulate
description of the nature of space and
time I think that our understanding of a
great many subjects will take a radical
leap forward so that is my best guess on
the breakthrough that we potentially
will be able to achieve in the future
nitro Phoenix asks parallel universe
please tell us about its possibility and
I can't tell you how many questions
about parallel universes I've been
getting of late and as I begin to answer
that question I'm going to ask anybody
who's listening to me who perhaps knows
how to contact my wife or my kids if you
could ask them to please bring me some
water because I had an hour session
before this and I am completely parched
so hopefully that could be put into
works as I at least in this universe
maybe that can be put into works so so
you may have heard or seeing the
headlines blaring out that NASA has
found evidence of a parallel universe in
which time elapses in Reverse I mean
have you seen have you seen those
headlines if you have just let me just
let me just say yes in the in the chat
here because I think they've been
getting a great deal of attention
because all of a sudden I'm asked about
parallel universes left right and center
so let me address that one first and
I'll address nitros question more
generally so what actually happened is
in the South Pole there was some
anomalous data very exciting some
particles called cosmic rays are
behaving in a manner that seems to be
incompatible with our understanding of
how they should be behaving roughly
speaking there's evidence at this
like Razer kind of traveling in the
wrong direction that's weird right
traveling in the wrong direction now
people have tried to explain this in
more ordinary ways the cosmic rays are
generally particles coming from outer
space the Sun slamming into the earth
creating particle Cascades that fall
downward could it be that their particle
Cascades happening say on the North Pole
and the particles are traveling through
the earth and emanating from the ice in
the wrong direction in that way it's not
impossible but certainly the energies
required of the neutrinos as these
particles are or we would have to have
certain value for them to be able to
travel through the earth but it seems to
be incompatible with the value that's
measured there have been more exotic
possibilities put forward - maybe
there's some supernova explosion that
happened in the other side and created
just the right particles to pass through
the earth and emerge in the South Pole
travel in the wrong direction
none of these are yet reaching consensus
so of course people put forward even
more wild possibilities such as maybe
there's a parallel universe where time
is elapsing the other direction if it
elapses the other direction then
particles that would be going this way
will now be going that way like running
the film in Reverse that's an
interesting idea it's also a far-out
idea it's an idea that would require a
tremendous amount of data and a mountain
of experimental evidence to really
believe it and we don't have anywhere
near that data or information yet so
it's not that it's an impossible idea
it's just there isn't enough support for
it so yes thank you my don't want you
say hello to the crowd over you did my
daughter Sophia she's brought me to
waters yeah I'm good thank you I'll see
you a bit later on don't get eaten by a
bear on the way home so that's that's
the story with the NASA headline it's
overblown as often these things are
clickbait if you will and it's
unfortunate because it kind of makes the
whole subject of parallel universes
turned into a cartoon again it's not
that the idea is impossible it's the way
it's being presented
is a caricature of the actual scientific
story that is developing and
unfortunately it's told with unnecessary
hyperbole
now tonight rose question could parallel
universes and generally possible the
answer is yes look I wrote a whole book
on this so I'd like to take the idea
seriously a book called hidden reality
and in there I go through nine different
flavors a parallel universe that modern
physics has revealed one is the many
worlds of quantum mechanics right in
quantum mechanics you can have this
result or that result but when you
measure 50% chance here 50% here you
only find one or the other outcome
where's the other outcome one of the
possibilities that people put forward is
it takes place in a parallel world Wow
interesting some people take this idea
very seriously do I think it's right
I think it's possibly right again I
don't think the evidence is yet in place
to say that it is right
the other possibility that for instance
people take seriously is multiple big
bangs our universe emerges from one big
bang but the fuel the so called in
photon field that gives rise to the
repulsive gravity that blows the
universe open that causes space to swell
if that is not fully used up in our Big
Bang as the math seems to suggest there
be leftover fuel that would power Big
Bang after Big Bang after Big Bang
universe after universe after universe
so I'm just laying out a number of ways
in which there could be parallel
universes so an answer to a question
that you're yes I think it's a real
possibility worthy of attention should
definitely be within our toolkit of
explanation when we encounter anomalies
but it will take a tremendous amount of
data to convince us that we've actually
encountered a parallel universe ok so
that's that's the power of parallel
universe story what do we have here
Christopher asks
that slipped away
Ali asks any thoughts about Tim Ian's I
don't know what Tim Ian's are sorry
maybe you want to clarify on that oh
gosh just go by too fast here or here's
one on
bill Paige from Mexico asks the bouncing
photon clock shows time dilation for
relative motion is there such a picture
for gravitational slowing of a clock
that's a that's an interesting question
so if you remember in one of the earlier
episodes or it's pretty commonly used in
discussions of special relativity you
can have a so-called light clock which
is two mirrors that are facing each
other and a ball of light that bounces
between them and the clock is basically
tic-tock tic-tock tic-tock it's the
round-trip travel of a photon that is
the tick and tock of this particular
weird bizarre but very useful notion of
a clock if that clock is then set in
motion then there's this argument which
is Bill is referring to in which the
photon now travels on the double
diagonal trajectory as the clock moves
over starts at the lower mirror bounces
up to the upper Merrit bounces down to
the lower mirror since the clock is in
motion from your perspective you see the
photon going in the double diagonal
that's a longer trajectory than the
straight up-and-down speed of light is
constant so if the light is traveling a
longer trajectory at the same speed that
will take less frequently time therefore
slows down on a moving clock a very
interesting example for understanding
how motion affects the passage of time
is there a simple analogy like that for
the gravitational slowing of time I
don't really know what I'm struggling
here to think of the best analogy that I
can think up and I don't have as clean
an example as the light clock maybe
someone in the comments maybe there may
be even countered in your reading or in
a course some beautiful little example
that summarizes the gravitational
slowing of time the way I've always
described it in more general terms is
normally we think about gravity as
pulling on matter but in some sense
gravity really does pull on the fabric
of space-time itself or said differently
gravity is the warping of space-time
itself so the slowing of time
from a gravitational field in some sense
is nothing but how should I say it a
tautology because the slowing of time is
what we meet by grabbing in other words
when objects fall you can shown the
general theory of relativity they're
falling because they head toward places
where time elapses more slowly that in
essence is Einstein's explanation of
familiar gravity as we experience it why
do we have a tendency to fall downward
and not upward why do we fall downward
and not upwards not even just a tendency
is what we do we do that because our
particles they are under rules that
drive them toward locations where time
elapses more slowly and time elapses
more slowly the closer you get to the
source of gravity so in that way it's
almost as though if you think about
gravity correctly it is the slowing of
time you don't even mean the light clock
or something to convince you of that
that's what we mean by gravity the
slowing of time in ordinary
circumstances like the gravity near the
surface of the earth so I don't know if
that's particularly helpful because it
does take really understanding the
general theory of relativity in a little
bit of detail to fully appreciate that
but that is is certainly how I think
about it ok what else do we have here
whoops Ave Ave Adha asks how big would
the Large Hadron Collider need to be to
prove supersymmetry and Avadhut the
answer is I don't know and nobody does
and the reason I say that is our
theories give us ample reason for
suspecting the existence of
supersymmetric particles these are
particles in addition to the familiar
particles like electrons quarks and
neutrinos these are particles that
differ from those particles by 1/2 unit
of spin
so for the neutrino that has spin 1/2
there's the neutrino scalar neutrino
that has spin 0 for the quarks there are
squawks that have spin 0 otherwise their
properties would be the same except for
their masses and that's the vital thing
the theories do not tell us the masses
of these particles and that's a drawback
because your answer the answer to your
question of how big a machine you need
is dependent on how massive the
particles are the more massive they are
the bigger the machine because the
bigger the energy necessary e equals
mc-squared
bigger mass bigger energy bigger energy
bigger machine and so the machine in
Geneva can probe to roughly about 10 TeV
what does that mean so a TV is a
thousand GeV a GeV is basically the mass
of a proton so the Large Hadron Collider
roughly can probe to ten thousand times
the mass of a proton
now if the supersymmetric particles were
in that range from the mass of a proton
to ten thousand times the mass of a
proton we should have seen them at the
Large Hadron Collider and we've not does
that prove that they don't exist it
doesn't it proves that they don't exist
in that mass range but there's a lot of
range still unexplored from roughly ten
thousand times the mass of proton all
the way up to the Planck mass which is
sort of the maximum possible mass before
these objects turn into black holes
themselves and the Planck mass is 10 to
the 19 GeV so that's 10 billion billion
times the mass per proton so between ten
thousand times the mass of proton and
ten billion billion times the mass per
proton is an unexplored window and so
that's the range that you'd have to
fully explore to rule out or perhaps to
find the supersymmetric particles and
that's a huge range and it's very
expensive
China may build the next machine that
maybe will probe the beginnings of that
realm between ten thousand and ten
billion billion times the mass for
proton but we just don't know how big
the machine will need to be to actually
prove the existence of through detection
or rule out by the non observe
observation of supersymmetric particles
okay hmm all right what do we have here
so there's an interesting question it's
a little bit involved but maybe as I try
to answer it I'll come up with a quick
way so Seth Catalano asks what is the
geometric intuitive difference between
the Ricci tensor and the Einstein tensor
I'm having trouble developing intuition
for these objects although I understand
the other curvature tensors and how to
think about that so so the Riemann
curvature tensor as you've seen in your
own studies obviously you've studied
this on your own also in your daily
equation is a tensor that has four
indices on it and it is the fundamental
gadget that allows us to measure
curvature and remember how we did that
we looked at parallel transport around
some arbitrary loop in a space and we
compared the direction of a tangent
vector moved
parallel to itself where parallel is
defined by the connection and we compare
that tangent vector to itself and the
difference between them is basically
given by the Riemann curvature tensor
contracted with elements that describe
the path how does the Ricci tensor
differ from that well the Riemann tensor
is giving you information about the
curvature of the entire space the Ricci
tensor you can think about is giving you
the curvature of various cross-sectional
slices of the space that are determined
by the remaining indices on the tensor
itself so in some sense the thing about
the two indices on the tensor is
defining
playing in the space at a given location
look at the plane spanned by the Mew and
new indices on the tensor and the Ricci
tensor is giving you information about
the curvature in that slice so that
hopefully gives you some rough sense of
what the the tensor is giving you okay
multi muti asks what if our universe is
mixing with its anti universe opposites
well that is a big question that people
struggle with why is there more matter
than antimatter in fact why is there any
matter at all if the universe treats
matter and antimatter on completely
equal footing and there's evidence that
it doesn't quite do that but there's
also strong evidence that to a large
extent it does if the universe treats
matter antimatter on the same footing
then you think that the same amount of
each would be produced and matter and
antimatter have the property that when
they meet each other they can annihilate
say into a spray of photons and
therefore you really would wonder why
there is any matter left at all how did
matter and antimatter get sequestered so
that they enter matters over there or
the matter over here or could it be that
somehow there is a small asymmetry and a
little bit more matter than antimatter
was produced in the period after the Big
Bang and the antimatter collided with
all of the matter that it could collide
with but since there's more antimatter
than matter there's some matter left
over from that process and you need
about one particle in a billion more
particles of matter than antimatter in
order for that the matter left over
could create all the stuff all the
galaxies all the stars in the world
around us so what's the answer to that
and there are various theories that have
been put forward but that asymmetry
either is generated dynamically the laws
themselves
create an asymmetry so they don't fully
treat matter and anti-matter on equal
footing that i think is a perspective
that most people take but there's also
the possibility that somehow matter got
separated from antimatter maybe the
annihilation will one day happen when
that sequestered state of the world is
no longer enforced or no longer the case
and that's sort of what Mattie muti is
asking if you mix these two together
what would happen and what would happen
is annihilation what would happen is
structures in the world would turn into
bursts of radiation and would be gone so
if there is sort of an antimatter galaxy
out there we just should hope against
hope that we don't pass through that
galaxy as it would not be fun for any of
the structures that define the galaxy as
we know it okay
Zubair Ahmad asked hi professor would
you be convinced with the answer of
Bertrand Russell that the universe just
is and well there's a lot of what
Bertrand Russell says that I am quite
taken by quite sympathetic to some of
the essays that he's written on
thermodynamics and the enemy in the far
future influence my own book influenced
until the end of time the book that I
came out with a few months back and I am
pretty much of the opinion that there is
no grand design
there is no overarching purpose the
universe came into existence for reasons
that no one yet understands but we're
getting closer and closer to it we can
explain how the universe evolved from a
fraction of a second after the beginning
that's impressive in its own right
that's amazing but we've yet to really
understand why there is something rather
than nothing and until we can answer
that question we have an incomplete
story
reality but certainly based on
everything I know everything I've
accounted everything I've studied over
the course of whatever thirty years of
being a professional physicist
everything to me suggests that the
universe is just the way it is that
there is nothing that designed the
universe there is design in the
structures of the universe and I think
we have a good understanding of how a
generalized version of evolution by
natural selection can yield those kinds
of organized complex collections of
particles we understand how gravity has
the ability to pull together ordered
structures like stars and planets out of
what otherwise is a chaotic mass of
particles so we understand at least in
rudimentary form how structure can come
into being and it's just the blind laws
of physics that are at work so from that
perspective there is no overarching
intelligence there's no overarching
design it is just the laws of physics
acting themselves on the particles of
matter and that's all there is to it
again that's incomplete I don't know
where the laws come from I don't know
where space and time come from I don't
know why there's something rather than
nothing there are theories they're ideas
these are open questions so modulo that
uncertainty I would say that I agree
wholeheartedly with the notion that the
universe just is okay what else have you
got here nhave ball asked professor
please explain about Hawking radiation
and I can say a few words about that it
emerged in 1974 from a brilliant paper
by Stephen Hawking and in this paper
Hawking puts together gravity and
quantum mechanics in a fairly
rudimentary form
but a form that is good enough to answer
certain kinds of questions not every
question in quantum gravity could be
answered by the approach that Hawking
took but he was able to analyze physics
near the edge of a black hole using this
blending of quantum mechanics and
general relativity and what he found is
that look an ordinary quantum mechanics
without black holes we learn that
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle in
some sense tells us that particles can
erupt out of the nothingness a particle
and antiparticle and erupt out of empty
space they can live for a very short
period of time they then encounter one
another annihilate and return to empty
space now that process we believe is
happening all the time throughout empty
space particles erupt through this
quantum fluctuation they live for a very
short period of time they annihilate
once they encounter each other a short
time later
Hawking re-examine that process not in
ordinary space but in the space just
outside the edge of a black hole and he
found that oftentimes what happens is
just like what happens anywhere else in
space the particles are up to find each
other
disappear but they also found a new
possibility that can occur near the edge
of a black hole which is this when the
particles are RuPt into existence in the
space just outside the edge of a black
hole one of the particles can get pulled
into the black hole
the remaining particle which is outside
the black hole does not have a partner
to annihilate with any longer so it
rushes off out into space and must it
actually must do that because if one
falls in the other must go in the
opposite direction to conserve momentum
so therefore what that means is at each
and every location on the edge of a
black hole this kind of process can take
place which from the outside looks like
particles streaming from the edge of a
black hole we don't see the partner that
falls in more over the partner that
falls in you can show has negative
energy almost like negative mass which
means as the black hole absorbs that
negative energy particle it
in heft it decreases in heft so you've
got radiation coming out from the edge
of a black hole as the black hole itself
gets smaller and smaller as I mentioned
before it's like a piece of charcoal
it's like a charcoal burning as the
charcoal burns it gives off radiation
and the charcoal itself gets smaller and
smaller
so in some sense Hawking radiation is
just like that
radiation emitted from quantum
fluctuations around the edge of a black
hole resulting in observers far away
seeing that radiation and at the same
time recognizing if the black hole
itself gets smaller and smaller that's
the basic idea of Hawking radiation so
new Raj Verma asks if Earth orbit is a
slight ellipse to conserve momentum and
speed increases when it's closest to the
Sun to be changes there's an
acceleration why can't we feel this
acceleration and I would even go further
Niraj right now the earth is spinning
around on its axis the earth is about
you know twenty five thousand miles in
circumference I know you guys hate miles
I still I was brought up a mile so I
still think that way when I'm just
talking about things in loose language
so the earth is about twenty-five
thousand miles around and it takes 24
hours for it to complete a rotation so
the earth is spinning around at a
thousand miles an hour
Wow that's pretty fast and of course
that's in circular motions that's an
acceleration all right why don't we feel
that want to feel any of these motions
and the answer is that these motions are
quite small the accelerations are quite
small even though it sounds like they're
quite big they're quite small relative
to the intrinsic pull of Earth's gravity
and therefore the intrinsic pull of
Earth's gravity we do feel that all the
time and according to Einstein that is
equivalent to an acceleration so we are
feeling acceleration all the time right
now I'm feeling that acceleration on you
know the seat of my chair
if you guys are sitting you're feeling
in the same way if you're standing up
you're feeling it on your feet and so
the idea is that the changes to the
acceleration from the processes that
you're talking about are so slight that
that we're not sensitive enough to feel
those changes but we are subject to
accelerations all the time not just from
the elliptical orbit but even from the
rotational motion of the earth let's see
that's see Peter asks a hot professor
Green could the Big Bang be some sort of
phase transition and absolutely it's
possible you know a phase transition you
understand that from ordinary real world
experience you go from ice to water
that's a phase transition from solid to
liquid you can go from liquid water to
gas that's another phase transition in
general in physics say in the
fundamental physics of the universe
phase transitions are associated with a
change of the value of a field like the
value of the Higgs field we're to change
value that would be a phase transition
and when you're looking at the swelling
of space in the Big Bang at least in the
inflationary theory you need the value
of the field to have a certain quality
it has to have a certain size and has to
be uniform within a region of space so
if you imagine that that field may have
had different values prior to the
inflationary expansion and then only
through a phase transition acquires the
uniform value in space that allows the
repulsive gravity to take hold then yeah
the inflationary expansion could well be
the result of a phase transition where
the value of the field jumps to the
value necessary for that repulsive
gravitational push to come into play
okay
what else I'm gonna take a look over so
haven't looked at in a while at the
YouTube thief not the YouTube the the
Twitter or Facebook feed if a photon
I can't claw asks if a photon is fired
directly into a black hole does it pick
up speed beyond the event horizon and
the answer is no if you appropriately
measure the speed of light the speed of
a photon and you do that in a local
measurement which is how you measure
speed something's racing by and you
measure the distance that it traverses
over a period of time as measured
locally you will always find that speed
of light is something a dum-dum the
speed of light constant the value does
not change and that's the only
definition of speed that you should use
when talking about the speed of an
object you don't want to use clocks that
are far away you don't want to use
rulers that are far away you want to use
clocks and rulers that are situated
where the object whose speed you're
measuring is actually located actually
moving and if you do that then the speed
of light and the general theory of
relativity is the speed of light
constant doesn't change um Margaretta
Dahlgren from sweden mama sounds like a
familiar name wend if I know that person
has my exact future existed from the
beginning of space time and if so in
which size shape and from what sense as
my exact future existed from the
beginning of space time and to that
answer I would say no I have to qualify
what I mean by that so
to mechanics which we believe is the
fundamental architecture of physical
reality quantum mechanics doesn't
predict definite results of how things
will evolve toward the future
quantum mechanics only predicts the
probabilities of how things will evolve
toward the future and so even in the
most simple of circumstances like the
motion of an electron we never predict
exactly where it will be or what its
motion will look like we only predict
the probability of these qualities of
the electron recognizing that quantum
mechanics allows for a kind of openness
in the future now the probabilities of
the quantum mathematics are determined
by Schrodinger's equation with the same
kind of deterministic aspect that we are
familiar with the determinism of
Newtonian physics the differences Newton
determines the outcomes quantum
mechanics determines the probabilities
of the outcomes so what I would say to
Margaretta is the probabilities for your
particles moving this way or that or
engaging in this manner or that or
coming together in this grouping or that
the probabilities were determined say
all the way back at the time of the Big
Bang or just after the Big Bang
but those probabilities do not actually
determine the behaviors that you will
undertake they only determine the
probability of those behaviors so your
future has existed in a probabilistic
sense in the sense of the various
possible futures in principle are
determined by quantum mechanics way
before you're born but that's different
from saying that your actual future was
determined it isn't under your control
but it is a random outcome of quantum
evolution but with the probabilities of
this or that outcome fully determined by
the equation so
a little bit subtle it's a little bit
more subtle than you might suspect so
the answer somewhere in between you
don't control your future but neither is
it the case that your future could not
have been otherwise your future could
have been otherwise one of the other
outcomes allowed by quantum mechanics
could have been the one that actually
took place okay what else do we have so
Ivan Flores if the universe is expanding
what is it expanding into and it's a
natural question I think that probably
everybody on this chat has asked
themselves at one point or another and
the point is that when you are talking
about the expansion of more familiar
objects what expands in the world well
you know bread expands my waistline
expands right when things expand they
expand within a pre-existing environment
so they are expanding into something and
therefore when you think about the
expansion of the universe the natural
thought is that space itself must swell
into a pre-existing environment but
things that are true for objects in the
universe need not be true for the
universe as a whole and this is an
example of that because our belief is
that the universe is not expanding into
pre-existing territories not like
there's some unclaimed land unclaimed
space out there and the universe does a
land grab and grabs hold of it as it
expands rather the idea is as space
expands
it's truly creating new space creating
space that did not exist until the
universe expanded so the new space that
is within an expanding universe is
created fresh it's not stale space out
there that is now reclaimed that's the
difference so it's not that the universe
is expanding into something is that
universe is creating the very space that
it then occupies as part of the spatial
expansion again on any of these
questions if if you feel that I've not
adequately addressed it or if you
disagree with my answer I'm more than
happy to hear well see your response and
and address it if I can
Paul C asks hi professor Greene I'm
really enjoying your new book thanks and
I thank you back Paul see what do you
think about Leonard Susskind's EPR
equals er theory and I should say it's
it's it's Leonard Susskind and whan
maldacena
so as I understand the history of that
idea Lennie and Wong were in
conversation and one day Wong sends
Lenny a cryptic email which says EPR
equals ER and that was sort of the
beginning of that way of potentially
thinking about things so what does it
mean first of all so EPR that's the
einstein-podolsky-rosen paradox is what
is often called but it's not a paradox
at all it's simply the recognition that
there can be these two distant particles
that are entangled and we've spoken
about entanglement here before where you
do something on one and it affects the
other so there can be threads of quantum
entanglement that link distant particles
er
that stands for Einstein and Rosen and
is referring to another paper that
Einstein wrote in the very same year
Einstein wrote his EPR paper in 1935 he
wrote as ER paper the R is the same
Rosen in both cases also in 1935 and the
ER paper has to do with wormholes
so wormholes we discuss a little bit
here earlier this possibility of tunnels
within the fabric of space and what
Lenny and Wong conjecture and give
evidence for is that the connections
established in ep are those quantum
entangled connections from
quantum mechanics in some sense are
equivalent to the wormhole connection
that comes out of the general theory of
relativity that's a stunning claim
right wormholes that come a classical
phenomenon the general theory of
relativity EPR entanglement is a feature
of quantum mechanics and they are
conjecturing that secretly these two
ideas may be the same and it is a
natural consequence of deeply thinking
about black holes and the radiation the
particles that emerge from a black hole
and the ways in which that radiation can
be entangled on the outside with
partners on the inside and what that
might mean for the geometry of the
environment that entanglement may
actually be nothing but a wormhole
connecting the product on the outside
and the protocol on the inside so so
it's a it's a beautiful idea it is one
that I find quite compelling and
convincing what it's actually fully
telling us about the nature of space and
time and black holes I think is still
yet to be a story that's fully written
but it is a major advance and it is an
important way of thinking about how the
classical concepts of wormhole and the
quantum mechanical concept entanglement
can come together in fact we're gonna do
just by way the advertisement we are
going to do a world science festival
program and all the world science
festival programs are going to be coming
out quite soon you may have seen the
Kavli prize announcement program that we
did on Wednesday I think it was but
we're going to be turning to our regular
world science festival programming and
start to turn those out over the coming
weeks and one of the programs that we're
going to do is this EP r equals ER and
Lenny's Huskie and I've told today is
going to be in that program which is
great and some of the other leaders in
quantum mechanics and string theory and
general relativity will also be in that
program so keep your eyes open for that
and we're will have a full
gushin of this idea of er equals e PR
that's coming up so thank you Paul C for
that question let's see what else we
have here
Siler gaming asks follow up on the idea
of expanding universe and thank you sada
I'd like follow-ups if the galaxies are
moving away from each other how does it
only signify that the universe is
expanding
and-and-and-and you're right I mean it
could be the case and imagine that the
universe is not expanding and what
happened is space is static it has
always existed not expanding and imagine
that you have a lot of matter at one
location within that pre-existing realm
and the matter just explodes and it gets
flung outwards and somehow the bits of
matter can coalesce as they're spreading
outward into galaxies or the galaxies
would all be rushing away from this
initial explosion could that be the
explanation of what is going on and most
physicists have long concluded that that
can't be the explanation for what's
going on and the reason is all of our
observations suggest that there is no
special location in space that the
universe is so-called homogeneous and
isotropic on sufficiently large scales
which means that our view of galaxies
all rushing away from us is the same
view that an observer on another planet
in another solar system and another
galaxy would see using powerful
telescopes every thing is rushing away
from everything else as opposed to
everything is rushing away from one
central location and in order to have a
situation which everything is rushing
away from everything else you need space
itself to be expanding and again the
balloon analogy it's hackneyed but it's
pretty darn good right so if you if you
have pennies on the surface of a balloon
I know you're rolling your eyes you've
heard it so many times but this
worth having it in mind again as you
blow air into the balloon and the
surface of the balloon stretches every
penny moves away from every other penny
on that surface it's not as though
there's some special penny from which
all galaxies are rushing away and it's
the only penny that can claim to be the
penny from which the others are rushing
every penny can make the same claim if
you think about it put yourself on one
of the pennies because it's the entire
surface of the balloon that's stretching
every penny looking out along the
surface of a balloon will see all the
other pennies rushing away and that is
our belief regarding the nature of the
motion of the galaxies and that is why
we explain them in terms of the
expansion of space itself it also fits
right into the general theory of
relativity
that's what Einstein's theories shows so
by virtue of the fact that we have
tested Einstein's thirty theory over and
over again
I mean Einstein's theory is kind of
incredibly ridiculously resilient it
successfully explains not only the
observations that started to happen in
the 1920s but a hundred years later it
explains the observation of
gravitational waves in fact predicts it
100 years later explains the black holes
that we now can actually take
photographs of so Einstein's theory is
just spectacularly resilient and so when
we realize that Einstein's theory can
explain the observations of the motion
of the distant galaxies in this very
simple beautiful economical way in terms
of the expansion of space when we see
that we realize that the evidence is
kind of overwhelming
so does that prove it it doesn't prove
it it's very hard to prove things in
science is the evidence overwhelming
that the expansion of space
is the explanation for the motion of
galaxies it is absolutely is but
definitely a good a good question to ask
all right
so pool ball asks the follow-up to that
why is it therefore that a galaxy does
not expand to and the answer is that
galaxies are held together by the
attractive version of gravity and that
attractive version of gravity as of
today is stronger than the repulsive
version of gravity that for instance is
driving the currently observed
accelerated expansion of the universe
why are our bodies not expanding again
our bodies are held together by
electromagnetic forces and the
electromagnetic force is holding my
particles together they are stronger
than the swelling of space and that's
why we hold together so if you are
expanding it is not because of the
expansion of space look for a different
cause now having said that we don't know
for instance about the dark energy which
is driving the accelerated expansion of
space we don't know the long-term
behavior of that dark energy and it is
possible and people have written down
models in which the repulsive
gravitational push get stronger and
stronger over time and if that's the
case then what I just told you which is
true today may not be true in the future
in the future it may be the case that
the outward swelling of space is
stronger
then the force is holding a galaxy
together and if that turns out to be the
case in the future then galaxies will
expand so pool ball the answer to your
question is in the future if the dark
energy increases in strength galaxies
will grow even stars will grow and
ultimately explode planets will explode
as the repulsive gravity drives
constituent particles apart even atoms
may be ripped apart by the repulsive
gravity by the force driving the
accelerated expansion in the future so
whereas today we hold together our
structural integrity is held intact by
the forces that hold us together that
may not always be true and the far
future the swelling of space may blow
everything apart that is a the
possibility that people do indeed study
okay what else here
so so abaca Farooqi asks how does
reverse in the direction of velocities
reverse the direction of time and I
would say it does not reverse the
direction of time so if you have for
instance a wineglass and I like this
example because we did it in a nova
program of mine years ago we allowed the
wineglass to fall off a table and smash
we then stopped the film and I ran
around in some subjective non real
version of time I ran around as the
shards were hanging in midair and I
reversed the direction of each of their
velocity vectors and with those reverse
velocity vectors we then allowed the
system to carry on forward and of course
what happens with the reverse rassa T
vectors is all the shards of glass jump
together and reassemble into the
pristine glass itself I would not call
that a reversing of time though I would
call that the observation in the
ordinary direction of time of a physical
process that we never see unfold in that
temporal order so a glass smashes a
glass can unsnap the unmasking is not
happening in Reverse time if I reverse
the velocities it is looking as though
the smash is being reversed it's looking
as though I've run the film backward but
if you're reversing velocities you're
watching the physical unfolding in
ordinary time it's just that you have
set up the initial velocities to do
something that we never see in the real
world which is to unbreak a glass but
that unbreaking process itself is taking
place in the ordinary direction of time
it's simply that you reverse the
velocities allowing the ordinary time
evolution to do something incredibly
unordinary incredibly extraordinary
which is to recreate a smashed recreate
a pristine glass from a smashed one
so it's very important to take the
distinction between reversing time going
backward in time and watching a physical
process unfold in the reverse temporal
order - two different things okay so
what else do we have here so
I don't know let me go over to some of
my questions from Twitter
Oh so Alexander from Twitter asks
professor green why didn't you use the
Hamiltonian operator when you talked
about the Schrodinger equation and I
would say Alexander that I didn't use
that language
but I did introduce the Hamiltonian
operator I didn't want to use
highfalutin
mathematical terms when they weren't
necessary and I do realize that for some
people it winds up becoming more
confusing to not use the high level
language because you've studied the
subject in a class that you use the high
level language and when I don't use
you're like well wait how does what he's
talking about relate to what I
previously learned so so sorry about
that for the few of you who are well
versed in in these ideas that I don't
always use the technical language but
when I introduced Alexander this idea of
minus d2 by DX squared right I had minus
H bar squared over 2m d2 by DX squared
plus V of X that is the Hamiltonian
operator nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics so I wrote it down but I
didn't label it so to connect it up with
things that you may have learned
elsewhere my operator differential
operator minus H bar squared over 2m d2
by DX squared plus V of X all that
acting on the wave function side that is
the Hamiltonian operator I just didn't
didn't use that language so I hope that
clarifies what I was going on about in
that episode on quantum mechanics
alpha-omega spy's says I enjoyed
listening to you the laws of physics do
not care whether you are vegetarian or
not so how do you feel whether your
choice of being a vegetarian comes from
the freedom of your will and I do not
tribute my choice to not eat meat
actually to be a vegan not just a
vegetarian I do not attribute that to
freewill as you know from either reading
my book you know chapter 5 I spend a lot
of time on freewill because if you're
trying to understand what it is to be
human on planet Earth within the context
of the cosmological unfolding you better
spend a little time thinking about
freewill because free will is for many
people the very definition of what it
means to be a human being we have the
freedom of choice the freedom of will
that's not available to say a rock or a
dandelion so do I believe that that
sensation of free will is real I do not
I think it is grossly misleading I think
we do not have the freedom of will that
our intuitions suggest that we do so
when it comes to any of my choices vegan
vegetarian choice a spouse did I freely
ask my wife to marry me
I did not I don't know if she's watching
right now actually I can see her window
from here and she seems to be not
reacting to what I just said so I
suspect that she's not listening or it's
on mute or something but I do not
believe that I freely asked my wife to
marry me
because I don't believe that I freely
make any choices it felt as though I was
making that choice it's an easy one in
case she's listening but I do I did feel
I did have the sensation of the freedom
of will that we all have and the
sensation is real but the actual act of
asking my wife to marry me was the
result of particles in my brain moving
in a particular manner that resulted in
my mouth and vocal cords making certain
motions that my wife interpreted as me
asking her to marry her and none of
those particle motions were under my
control what would it mean for particle
motion to be under my control it's
absurd I don't control the motion of
particles how would I do that the laws
of physics determine particle motion and
what I think and feel is the result of
that motion
I don't even know what it would mean for
me to control the particle what does
that mean doesn't make any sense how can
I a collection of particles control the
motion of the particles I don't have
some kind of extrasensory force capacity
electromagnetism weak strong nuclear
forces gravitational forces those are
the forces that depend on not dependent
those are the forces that yield the
motion of particles so the motion of
particles depends on those forces in
those forces I don't control them
neither do you
so even beyond vegetarian/vegan free
will none of it
do I believe emerges from the
traditional notion of the freedom of
choice so zeros skull asks god god god
exists as an idea in the mind of
everyone who has such an idea but it is
different in every mind therefore
imaginary well I get what you're talking
about zero skull it's actually a point
that Richard Dawkins is fond of making
Richard Dawkins emphasizes that there
are many different religions practiced
on planet Earth and even within a given
religion as you point out zero skull
many people have different perspectives
on what the nature of God is and if
we're not all agreeing if all the
religions are not agreeing then that
suggests that there isn't any
fundamental truth that they are tapping
into and in fact you know Richard likes
to say that most religions deny the
viability of other religions right most
religions say that their view of God in
the world is the right one and that the
other religions are misguided and
therefore in some sense every religion
articulates the belief that the other
religions are irrelevant to truth and
Richard likes to say
as an atheist all he does is what every
world religion does but he goes one step
further he denies the reality of one
more religion in any given perspective
and thereby takes it down from one to
zero and it's an interesting argument
and I have a certain degree of
receptivity to that way of thinking
about things but you know it's possible
it's possible that one religion is right
and all the others are wrong right and
it could be that within that religion
there is one view of God that is right
and all the other views are wrong
that's not logically impossible it's not
logically ruled out by the fact that
many people say different things
many people say different things about
you know why a ball flies through the
air now if you're a physicist and you
know physics you give one answer but you
do a you do a poll of Americans about
why a baseball flies through the air and
I'm sure you're gonna get a lot of
answers that are utterly wrong and that
doesn't mean just because many people
have different perspectives that there
is no truth about the motion of the ball
there is and we approach that truth
through the language of physics so I
think it's a little quick to say that
just because there isn't universal
agreement on what God is that God
doesn't exist too fast
on the other hand I think there are
other arguments that give strong reason
for
trying to understand the object of world
through the language of science not
through the language of religion and if
you want to talk about that was I'm
happy to but even though I'm of a
similar mindset to say Richard not
identical but similar another mindset I
think that resonates with your question
I don't think that you can reason in the
manner that you did and in that way rule
out every religion just because everyone
doesn't agree on what the right religion
is ali al-taher asks do you love your
wife yeah I sure do love my wife do I
have freedom in that trust I don't am I
happy that that I that I'm in this
situation that I have a wife that I love
yeah but do I have any choice in that
fundamentally no I don't
there may not in the slightest and I
happened that I'm not a rock that isn't
able to experience the kinds of emotions
that a more complicated arrangement of
particles is able to I am is that
sometimes painful sure is it sometimes
wonderful absolutely am i thankful for
the range of reactions that this kind of
collection of particles is able to
undergo compared to say a rock which
kind of doesn't do much but sit there
yeah much more interesting what's
Reviver it
but do I have control over the
motion of those particles and therefore
control over the motion of particles
yielding the reactions and sensations
that I experience now I don't
just how it is okay well I'm exhausted
too dad I guess it's cuz I did an hour
before this I'm gonna for you guys any
of you guys were there but I did this
reddit public access network I did that
for an hour before this so how long we
been talking we've only been talking
hour and a half but I'm at the two and a
half hour mark right now I'm starting to
feel it so I don't know how how long
I'll go today but as long as I as long
as my voice holds up so let's keep going
here then I'm gonna try to get this
scroll from there's a follow up I so
follow up with question it with the
exclamation mark sai yok says what if we
are also getting expanded along with the
entire universe as they're also part of
space there was just a reference object
in this University compare it so that
that's that's certainly true you know if
if truly everything is expanding at the
same rate then you'd have no benchmark
to measure anything against anything
else but that would be sort of an
unobservable kind of expansion the
observable sort of expansion is the
expansion that we witness where it is
not simply that the very definition of a
meter is now two meters or a little
later it's defined to be three meters or
it's probably the reverse you know if
you want to truly expand what we what we
called three meters in the past is now a
meter so that length in some sense is
the new standard so you're right
but we're not that interested in
unobservable qualities of world you know
sometimes people talk about you know the
the buddhist god what's the word co on
got the right word i think it is you
know the puzzle what is the sound of one
hand clapping you know that one you can
solve by the way and if you guys had
visual i'm sure that you would show me
the solution but what is the solution to
the issue the sound of one hand clapping
it's one hand clapping
can you hear that there it is done we
saw that one let's move on but there are
questions about the world that are
fundamentally unanswerable not that one
but you know things changing in a way
that's completely the same for
everything you know if we were to say
that time time just sped up by a factor
of two but for everything every process
that would be an unobservable change to
the world right because the very
standard of time would be subject to
that increase in speed so unobservable
so that those are just not that
interesting to us though the ones that
are are interesting are the measurable
changes and those are the ones that we
talked about we talked about the
expanding universe the expansion of
space oh here's a very interesting
question Cambridge breaths Cambridge
breaths asks hi Brian what is your
opinion about Freeman Dyson's theory
that nature will never allow us to
measure a single graviton in fact the
very observation will turn that process
into a black hole and and I wonder how
widely Freeman wrote about this idea I
read about it I think in the New York
Review of Books where Freeman loved to
publish these wonderful erudite reviews
and articles and I think it was in that
publication that he noted this
contrarian perspective that not only did
he say that gravitons could not be
measured he basically said they may not
even exist his view was maybe don't need
to put gravity and quantum mechanics
together he said look quantum mechanics
does its job in the realm of particles
molecules atoms and so forth general
tivity does its job in the realms of
gravity matters stars and galaxies and
he basically said it's misguided to
think that there has to be a unified
theory that puts gravity and quantum
mechanics together
and by the way if you don't put gravity
and quantum mechanics together you don't
have a graviton the graviton is not
something you find in a classical
textbook on Einstein's general theory of
relativity you find the graviton only in
circumstances where one is using quantum
mechanical ideas in a situation that
involves gravity but if you believe
Freeman Dyson and you don't have to put
the two theories together then there
isn't such a thing as a graviton now why
don't we take this idea more seriously
well look it's possible it's true but
the reason we don't take it seriously is
because we're aware of physical
situations in which as far as we can
tell gravity and quantum mechanics have
to be blended together for instance the
R equals zero location of a black hole
so somebody actually on on YouTube I
remember seeing this question I think
it's Bernard Mick Garvey was asking he
said look you know when you solve the
equations of Einstein's general theory
of relativity and get the black hole
solution it's only valid outside the
mass responsible for the solution so are
equal to zero that singularity maybe you
just can't ignore it maybe it's outside
the realm of the solution and sure you
can say that but still they are equal to
zero location as far as we can tell is a
real location we want to understand the
physics at that real location it's true
that the Schwarzschild solution is not
valid there that's what that singularity
means the article to infinity but what
is valid at R equal to zero and we think
that you need to put quantum mechanics
together with Einstein's theory that's
why the Schwarzschild solution is not
valid at all right the de xira doesn't
take quantum mechanics into account so
according to Freeman Dyson maybe you
could just ignore it much as Barnard is
suggesting but as far as we can tell
there's a real is a real spot in
space-time called R equal to zero and
without quantum mechanics and gravity
coming together
understand it so that's why you need to
blend them together similarly the T
equal to zero moment of the Big Bang
it's another circumstance in which the
math breaks down you could just ignore
it and say well whatever the universe
starts not a time equal to zero we're
gonna ignore that just start it later on
sure you can do that but if you want to
truly understand how the universe came
to be and not just lock it away in a
black box called ignorance you've got to
go deeper you've got to go to T equal to
zero for the Big Bang and at T equal to
zero you've got to put quantum mechanics
and general relativity together because
it's an incredible amount of matter
crushed to a very small size small size
quantum mechanics incredible amounts of
matter general relativity so these are
the reasons why we're not receptive to
Dyson suggestion that we just keep the
two theories apart and if you put the
two theories together then indeed you
have gravitons in the gravitational
story could you ever go about measuring
them as you note in your question were
they in some sense turn into black holes
yeah maybe but black holes can be
detected right astronomical black holes
you saw a photograph of them a black
hole in the laboratory it would just be
an unusual particle if it had a mass of
a particle so again there doesn't seem
to be any ironclad reason to suspect
number one that graviton it's don't
exist number two that they couldn't be
detected so bottom line is I'm not
predisposed to I even predisposed my
reasoning suggests to me that Dyson's
account is not right
okay si monster asks what is gauge
symmetry holy smokes that's a tough one
dad is a tough one um I don't even know
if I'm gonna try to answer that question
so oh my goodness how do I answer that
in an ordinary language that's that's a
hard one um you know what si monster if
my brain was more fresh I suspect I
might be able to come up with a quick
explanation but I'm I'm going on two and
a half hours for the other one and my
brain is not quite as fresh so I am
going to put off that question ask it
next week and next week I'm gonna take
it early on and see what I can do with
that but it's a hard question very hard
question it's hard question to say now
I'm mathematica of course oh yeah so let
me do this to answer your question I may
answer it mathematically not something
our ordinary do but this is called your
daily equation after all so good so what
is a gauge symmetry so when we write
down the equations of for instance with
standard model of particle physics we
find that those equations respect
certain symmetries those symmetries are
generally Li groups which are built upon
Li algebras and the symmetry group of
the standard model of particle physics
is the group su 3 + su 2 cross u 1 and
that group can be thought of as a group
of transformations that act on the
quantum fields in the standard model
Lagrangian so what does a gauge symmetry
a gauge symmetry is the transformation
of the fields in a given Lagrangian by a
given Li group that leaves the
Lagrangian of the theory invariant or it
most changes it by a total derivative in
time and such a symmetry is called a
gauge symmetry for historical reasons
but that's what a gauge symmetry is
okay so captain frantic says stand back
he's doing math didn't understand far
back it's not that bad so what else have
we got here
[Music]
Yvonne or Ivan Flores asks professor how
did cosmic inflation flattened the
universe and first of all Ivan or Yvonne
I'm sure I don't know what the right
pronunciation is when people talk about
the universe being flat that can be a
confusing idea from the get-go flat
usually for me brings to mind the
picture of a pancake or if you're in
France a CREP you know something that's
really thin and flat and that's not what
we mean when we talk about the universe
being flat what we mean by the universe
being flat is that the universe doesn't
have spatial curvature and it's hard to
think about spatial curvature in a
3-dimensional sense because when we talk
about curved objects in space you know
we can picture that right here we go
here so this is actually here's a curved
object people recognize that actually
the cylindrical part of there's not
actually curved it's simply the way it's
embedded in three-dimensional space but
here's like a actually curved space this
is uh this is a you know a nice mug
beetles monk given to my son Alec by two
fellas we work with in the UK named Al
and Al and that's a curved object in a
three dimensional space but to picture
the curvature of three dimensional space
itself it doesn't exist within space and
it's very hard to picture so we often
use two dimensional analogies and two
dimensional analogy for a curved shape
would be say the surface of a basketball
right that's a curved surface and a flat
version of that would be the crap or the
pancake where it's not got that
curvature its flattened out but you
have to scale it up to three dimensions
so when we talk about flattening the
universe it's not like flattening the
universe into a pancake it's removing
any spatial curvature that the
three-dimensional spatial section the
slice of the universe of the universe
might have and so now the question is
how does cosmic inflation get rid of
curvature in that sense again I'm going
to use the two-dimensional analogy
because it's so hard to picture
curvature in 3-space
but scale this up to three dimensions to
really understand what's going on let's
take that basketball the surface of the
basketball is curved two-dimensional but
let's use it so we can picture things if
you make the basketball larger and
larger let's say you make the basketball
as large as planet Earth then you'll
notice that the curvature has been
reduced right as I look out on the
surface of planet Earth yeah there's
some little indentations and so forth
but overall it looks flat that's where
we get the flat earther perspective that
I don't know if we spoke about in this
chat or if it was in the previous one
that I was in just before this but if
you look out at the world the surface of
the earth looks flat even though we know
that it's not simply because it's so big
so the lesson is when you take a surface
and you make a bigger and bigger and
bigger it becomes flatter and flatter in
any local region making something bigger
makes it appear flatter now apply that
to the three dimensions of the universe
what is inflation do it makes the
universe grow by an enormous factor in a
short period of time by the same
reasoning if the universe had any
curvature spatial curvature when it was
expanded by a huge factor that curvature
is diluted just like the curvature of a
basketball is diluted when you make it
as large as the earth the curvature of
space itself is diluted as it gets
larger through the swelling of
inflationary expansion so Ivan that's
the answer to your question that's how
cosmic inflation flattens the universe
doesn't flat
this way it flattens if I'm making the
scale so much larger which diminishes
the amount of curvature in any local
region good question though
so anu asks a related question why would
cosmic inflation want to get rid of the
curvature so very anthropomorphic but I
use that language too so I can't
criticize you for that that would be
throwing bricks in a glass house but I'm
not exactly sure what you mean a new by
why would cosmic inflation want to get
rid of Kircher I'm gonna interpret that
to mean why would physicists be happy
that cosmic inflation gets rid of
curvature so I hope you don't mind my
rephrasing and the reason why we're
excited and happy that cosmic inflation
can dilute curvature is for the
following reason in the pre inflationary
version of the Big Bang before inflation
came on the scene we faced a bit of a
problem and the problem was in order for
the evolution of the universe in its
expansion to yield the amount of
curvature that we now measure which is
quite small compatible in fact was zero
but it's quite small for the universe
today to have a small amount of
curvature in the ordinary pre
inflationary version of Big Bang you
would have had to tune the curvature of
the spatial slices of the universe in
its early moments by something like one
part in 10 to the 50 because in the pre
inflationary version of the Big Bang
curvature grows over time it doesn't
dilute in the way that I have explained
and if it grows over time then it had
better be so close to zero in the early
universe so that after the amount of
growth that it's had since the Big Bang
it can still be a small number the small
number that we currently measure people
don't like that businesses don't like a
theory that requires you to tune
quantities to say 50 decimal places it
just feels unnatural it feels
it feels artificial the beauty of the
inflationary theory is because of this
rapid swelling and hence dilution of the
curvature regardless of what curvature
of the universe had in its earliest
moments it will be diluted to nearly
zero by today through the inflationary
expansion ah that's beautiful
we love theories like that we love
theories where you don't have to
fine-tune things early on where it
doesn't matter hardly what the curvature
was early on within reason because the
dynamics dilutes it to the small value
that we currently witnessed that's why
we're happy that inflation gets rid of
in the language of on ooh ha si gets rid
of the spatial curvature
okay so
yosh Paul asked should we take Penrose
diagram seriously yeah definitely take
them seriously as a mathematical tool
for analyzing the global structure of
space-time the beauty of the Penrose
diagram is it can take points that are
at infinity arbitrarily far apart and
through a clever rescaling bring them
into a finite looking distance in the
Penrose diagram allowing you to see the
full structure of the space-time so
don't take it seriously say in terms of
the distances that you see on a page
reflecting the distances out there in
the world know that rescaling is not
part of reality but that rescaling is a
powerful mathematical tool so you can
understand the reality so in that sense
you can take it seriously and should
take it seriously
so Shahab olofi asks where does energy
come from and the most honest answer is
I don't know nobody really has an answer
for why there's something rather than
nothing which is a equivalent kind of
question but there are interesting
theories that suggest that because the
gravitational potential energy can be
negative remember what you learned in
school the potential energy of gravity
goes like minus GM over R - right
gravitational potential energy is -
which means it can be arbitrarily
negative so imagine a circumstance in
which the energy that we see in the
world around us that positive energy is
exactly balanced by a negative amount of
gravitational potential energy yielding
a total energy including both
contributions of zero then we wouldn't
have to answer the question of where
does the energy come from because it's
zero it's just broken apart in an
interesting manner positive that we see
balanced by the negative gravitational
potential energy that we often don't
take account of in our intuitive
accounting of the energy in the universe
that's one possibility we don't know
that that's the answer but at least it's
one possibility in which you wouldn't
have to answer the question of what's
the ultimate source of the energy
because the total mountain be zero and
you've just divided it up into some
positive and some negative in a useful
way
they could ask what what divided it up
and that can take you into inflation and
cosmology and other things with that
sort but it refrains the question in
interesting a different way Allah sorry
Alaa I don't mean to be sacrilegious Ya
Allah o Allah sorry my question is when
the fabric of space-time bends
how can a 4d space contain it anymore in
analogy as if we bend paper it will no
longer be sufficiently it can only be
contained in the plane so yeah you're
absolutely right if if you lived in a
two-dimensional universe and then you
bend the surface if you want to embed it
in a Euclidean space in an ambient
environment then you're right you can no
longer embed it in a two-dimensional
environment but bear in mind that to a
little ant walking on that piece of
paper whether it's bent or curved that
ant is still experiencing a
2-dimensional reality so to the end the
ant doesn't need to embed the space in a
higher dimension sometimes we find it
useful mathematically to visualize a
curved space by embedding it in an
ambient environment but you don't need
to do that you can talk totally
intrinsically when you're talking about
the geometry of curved space-time
environments but you're right if you
want to embed our universe if our
universe has some interesting complex
not complex in the sense of imaginary
numbers but some intricate curvature
then yeah you'd have to embed our
universe in a higher dimensional space
if you want that higher dimensional
arena to say be flat in the sense of
having no curvature and you wouldn't
need a higher dimensional space to do
that and sometimes it's useful to do
that but sometimes it's not sometimes
just talking completely intrinsically we
are the ants walking on the piece of
paper we are the ants inhabiting an
environment that does not need to be
embedded in a higher dimensional
environment that's fine
if they're higher dimensional beings
that like to visualize things the way
that we do they might think about
embedding our universe in a higher
dimensional expanse but we don't have to
do it we're perfectly happy dealing with
our universe intrinsically not
extrinsically so by chaco says
Methuselah and yeah I don't know what
that means in this context but actually
I just reread George Bernard Shaw's
beautiful play on Methuselah and it's
called back to Methuselah and I
encourage you to check that out and read
it it's a very interesting survey it's
almost like it's almost honestly it's
almost like my book until the end of
time because it begins at the beginning
and it goes hit again but it does it
through a fictional account of
characters dealing with different
versions of mortality and immortality so
it's kind of a nice companion to my book
in a fictional setting so if you if you
if you like that sort of stuff you
should definitely check out it's old but
you can still get hold of it back to
Methuselah by George Bernard Shaw like I
should have such a son that book to the
class I'm teaching right now on my book
mm-hmm yeah I think I may do that
Hammad Ali asks how can we access
another dimension and one possibility if
there are other dimensions is through
high energy collisions at the Large
Hadron Collider our hope is that when
you slam protons against protons that
some of the debris that's created
through the collision might be able to
leave our dimensions and enter another
dimension for instance a dimension that
suggested by string theory how would you
know that well if you slam particles
together and some of the debris leaves
our dimensions and goes into another
dimension that we don't have direct
access to we would notice that process
by virtue of there being less energy
after the collision than before the
collision so you add up
the energy of the say two colliding
protons you add up the energy of all the
debris that you can get your hands on
that the detectives detect and if the
energy of all that debris adds up to a
number that's less than the energy that
you started with that could be evidence
of what you're asking that could be
evidence of accessing another dimension
it could be evidence of particles
wafting out of our dimensions and
entering into other dimensions we have
never seen a process like that
unfortunately it'd be hugely exciting to
have a whole mountain of data
supporting the idea of these missing
energy signatures supporting the idea of
extra dimensions but unfortunately we
don't have any such data of that sort
yet in fact I was thinking now that you
asked about extra dimensions we have a
video that we created about extra
dimensions I don't know if any of you've
seen my string theory video where I'm in
an environment and all these things
happen around me oranges grow strings
vibrate violins grow out of my chin
allow me to explain the basic idea of
string theory if you have seen that
video and and liked it let me know
because we have another video in the
same visual look but on extra dimensions
and that might be we've never released
it may be fun to release that now that
many people are home hanging out
searching for interesting things to look
at and maybe we'll release that in the
next couple of weeks and it's sort of a
fun example of the of thinking about and
imagining extra dimensions of space okay
aashiq rayel asks professor grant
according to dr. Tyson which I presume
is dr. Neil Tyson because there's other
Tyson's in the in the worlds of physics
if Earth turned into a black hole moon
still rotated around Earth is that mean
curvature of space-time don't depends on
its mass density darn I'm having trouble
parsing that one a little bit but I'll
interpret it to mean the following if
you have a spherical body like the earth
it gives rise to a certain gravitational
field around it and that gravitational
field in the general theory of
relativity is reflected in the
space-time curvature in the environment
outside earth now if you were to squeeze
earth down to the size of a black hole
you have to squeeze it down to like a
couple centimeters across or something
the only change you know to be
gravitational waves
but let's imagine that you just sort of
somehow replaced the earth by a smaller
earth the gravitational field in the
environment outside the distance from
the Earth's center to its surface right
so roughly whatever four thousand miles
or something the gravitational field out
there wouldn't change at all the only
thing that would change is you could now
travel closer and closer to the sources
of gravity because the Earth's surface
would no longer get into your way if you
crushed it down to a centimeter across
so if your question is that the
gravitational field due to a spherical
body only depends on its mass the answer
is that you you know I'm not talking
about things like rotation and electric
charges over the answer to that yes
there's a powerful theorem called
birkhoff's theorem and birkhoff's
theorem tells us that the gravitational
field outside a spherical body is just
dependent upon its mass so in that sense
I think the question you're asking is if
you crush it down to a tiny little
nugget of the same mass would it
ultimately yield the same gravitational
field far away and the answer is yes
absolutely yes okay so so Kerr CaroMont
asks why are we so smart other animals
do not even get close well I kind of
have some sympathy with that every time
you know I've been accused strangely
enough I don't know I've been accused by
some people of not giving animals enough
credit not giving animals enough credit
regarding their language capacities and
I kind of feel bad that I give that
impression
I do think
a difference between us and animals with
the level of sophistication of our
language I have read studies that have
tried to analyze the information content
in the utterances of other species and
by any measure that seems reasonable
it's clear that the information content
is less than the information content in
the utterances that we humans make you
can just sort of analyze the variation
in the sonic waveform and the variation
in ours the realm or the spread of
variation in the sonic form allows for
it to carry more information than the
spread in the wave form of other animals
whose utterances have been analyzed is
that airtight could there be some other
quality of their utterances that carries
information and maybe they know more
than we do or have much more
sophisticated communication than we are
aware of it's possible it's just I don't
see any evidence for that and when I say
I I don't do these studies linguists do
these studies so maybe there are other
studies that I'm not aware of that have
given evidence that in the animal
kingdom besides human beings there is a
level of communication that I'm not
aware of and I'd be interested to know
of those references if you have any but
putting those possibilities to the side
there is something special about our
mode of communication there's something
special about what we can do with our
ways of analyzing the world both through
ordinary language and through the
language of mathematics and why are we
able to do that I would say the reason
we're able to do that is because we're
the beneficiary of generation upon
generation upon generation of
evolutionary advancement evolution by
natural selection has allowed us to head
off in a direction that is quite unique
and quite special and I don't know that
dogs are able to solve on Stein's field
equations I don't know the cats or
fish or dolphins are able to analyze
Schrodinger's equation to get the
spectral lines of hydrogen maybe they
can or maybe they do other things that
are so spectacular that along a
different axis we are the less
intelligent species and they are the
more intelligent species again I don't
see any evidence for that but the bottom
line is evolution by natural selection
is a powerful force that allows
molecules and structures to get ever
more refined in their organizational
structure and we have so exquisitely
organized that we don't have to limit
our language and our thinking to the
moment most animal communication that I
am aware of is for the most part focused
on issues of the moment a predator of
the moment an opportunity of the moment
a danger of the moment what we humans
can do is we can use the power of
language to rise above the now and
really think about the past and analyze
the future contemplate what was and
imagine what will be I don't think
elephants can do that
I don't think elephants can predict that
the Sun will swell to a red giant in 5
billion years Dave Emeril I don't think
dolphins are able to calculate that the
lifetime of a solar mass black hole is
about 10 to the sixty-eight years I
don't think they can calculate that I
don't even think they can contemplate
that am I wrong
I don't think so but I'd love to hear
views if you think otherwise
so mr. castle asks is there a quantum
mechanical equation showing why we can't
predict the time for radioactive decay
for a single atom and and there is I
mean it's right there in the Schrodinger
equation with the interpretation of the
wave function given to us by Max Born so
this was a subject of at least one of
your daily equation episodes and in the
Schrodinger equation and in the wave
function is intrinsically a notion of
probability intrinsically a notion of
probability that's what the wave
function is it's a mathematical
articulation of the probabilities of one
or another outcome and because it's in
the language of probability all you can
ever say is there's a 50% or 30% or a
90% chance or a 1% chance of this that
or the other thing happening and
radioactive decay is one of those things
so you can only predict the probability
of the decay happening as opposed to
when it will definitely happen and that
is the nature of the beast in a world in
which probabilities are so intimately
interwoven into the nature of reality
so Lauren crew asks a follow-up based on
that thought I'm not sure which that
thought is but probably something
earlier your thoughts and consciousness
yeah no you've told me what thought
Thank You Lauren so based on that
thought your thoughts and consciousness
in string theory do you think there is a
much larger and single consciousness and
no is my answer I'm not saying that
there can't be and again I'm not
dogmatic and I and I and I hope I don't
come across as dogmatic even when I
forcefully describe my point of view I
describe things forcefully both verbally
and in written form because I get
excited about these ideas and there are
certain ideas that I feel very strongly
about because they so directly emerge
from our understanding of the physical
universe and the ingredients making up
the physical universe but I'm not
dogmatic but when I think about
consciousness Lauren I think about it in
the incarnation that I am aware of and
the only incarnation of consciousness
that I am aware of is my own
consciousness and it takes place in a
brain and then I extrapolate from that
to allow for consciousness to exist in
other brains and by other reports of
people in the world around me they seem
to confirm that that indeed is what's
going on other people claim to be
conscious I don't know that's true but
I'm willing to admit the possibility
because they have a brain much like my
own since my brain allows me to be
conscious I will admit there's a
likelihood that their brain allows them
to be conscious good ok and then I look
at animals dogs and cats and their
behavior seems to suggest that they have
a certain degree of conscious awareness
as well and they also have a thing much
like mine slightly different form in
their heads called the brain of their
species is what I'm willing to allow
that their brains are also centers of
conscious awareness but I don't see any
evidence for any kind of conscious
awareness that stands outside
some kind of brain
or some kind of physiological system
that we would call alive I want to even
be a little bit more broader and
therefore the notion of some kind of
universal consciousness that presumably
would inhabit space and time as opposed
to inhabit a brain is not something that
I'm led to posit because I don't see any
evidence for any kind of conscious
awareness outside of the motion of
particles inside an organized structure
called a brain you might call that
limited thinking I call it thinking
based on the evidence based on the facts
based on our understanding of how the
world seems to work I am open to the
aliens coming down and saying you guys
are so limited in your thinking or or or
Brian Greene you're so limiting your
thinking why didn't you listen to Lauren
Crewe it was more expansive and and
they're thinking and that could happen
it could happen but I just don't see any
evidence for it and therefore I
entertain it as an interesting mind
tickling possibility I don't entertain
it as something that I want to integrate
into my worldview at least not yet I
hope that addresses the question Laura
and feel free to follow up if you have
other thoughts that have not addressed
there so
progress asks we'd love to hear your
thoughts on the opto nians
and what role this discrete number
system could play in the bigger
understanding of our universe I haven't
seen this subject touched and for those
of you who aren't familiar with the octo
nians but hopefully are familiar with
imaginary numbers so imagine a numbers
you know introduce this new number
called I where I squared is equal to
minus one and that proved very useful in
physics it's not that we have devices
that measure imaginary numbers but the
mathematical tool of imaginary numbers
is a very powerful one we see it at work
in quantum mechanics we see it at work
in the wave theory more generally and so
the natural question is if the move from
real numbers to imaginary numbers was
useful
are there other moves to other number
systems that might be equally or even
more powerful and impactful and indeed
there's a natural progression which is
where we get to inspire progress is
question you can go from the imaginary
numbers to I guess are called the
Hamiltonian or Cayley numbers you know I
J and K for I squared equals minus when
Jace critics my case good his minor
items Jake was K items K equals minus J
and so forth and that's an interesting
number system then there's the another
one the octo nians
so imaginary number you just have I and
minus 1 so I squared is minus 1 so you
said we got two numbers there for the
next step you have for I J and K and I
squared equals minus 1 Z minus 1 I J and
K you have the octo needs we have 8 such
ingredients that come together in an
interesting structure and might that of
B have my kind of physical relevance and
and people have actually studied this
people have gone into all sorts of
interesting discrete number system
p-adic numbers based on the prime P if
you are familiar with those there's a P
attic version of string theory that
people have developed but I don't I
don't really I don't know that these
have had any great success they're
interesting mathematical structure
and maybe someone can correct maybe
there is some deep use of the octo nians
in physics I can't really think of I'm
probably missing something obvious and
just having a moment of brain old-age
amnesiac here but I don't really know of
any good example of the octo nians where
I can say to you
aha if it wasn't for the octo nians we
would never really have been able to
analyze X someone tell me about X's and
I don't really know of an example but I
do know there had these you know fun P
attic examples of string theory again I
wouldn't say that they've done anything
deep for us just yet but the fact that
they exist is certainly interesting so I
saved the jury's out the other thing
that the jury's out on that people often
ask me about is you know there are
different kinds of topologies different
topologies different notions of nearness
and different notions of open sets that
you can make use of in even you know
higher dimensional spaces that we study
or in four dimensions they're different
differential structures do these have
any role in physics I don't know again
and people have written down papers with
using different differential structures
different notion of derivatives they've
written down papers using different
topological structures on higher
dimensional spaces but I've never really
seen anything come out of it where I can
say and this is the deep insight into
our world that has emerged from these
studies so again jury is still out I
hope that answers the question inspire
progress um let's see what else we want
to deal with here so Jo Siebert asks if
there is a limit to how fast a particle
can move through space is there also a
limit to how fast it can move through
time and what I would say is I think the
best way of answering that question is
there is a limit in fact a very precise
number that describes how fast a
particle moves through space-time rather
than breaking it up into space and time
separately
it's more profitable to think about it
particles motion through space-time and
in a very real sense the speed of a
particle through space-time is always
equal to the speed of light always equal
to the speed of light so there's a fixed
and never changing speed through
space-time that describes the velocity
of particles through space-time itself
now when you break that up into space
and time and as interesting consequences
because if there's a fixed speed through
space-time then if you're not moving
through space then all of that motion
through space time is through time and
that is the rate at which you age if
however you're like a photon and you're
always moving through space at the speed
of light then there's nothing left to
move through time and that comes this
poetic notion of photons not ageing
photons experience in some sense all the
time at once if you are a regular person
like me and you get up and you start to
walk through space then you are
diverting some of your fixed amount of
motion through space-time into that
motion through space and there is less
speed left over to go through time and
that explains why your motion through
time slows so if I'm watching you and
you go up and walk well before you walk
I would say all your motion is through
space-time you're moving through
space-time at the speed of light as you
get up and start to walk I say you now
have diverted some of your previous
motion through space-time into motion
through space and therefore you've got
less left over to move through time and
therefore I will conclude that your
motion through time will slow down and
indeed it does slow down that is the
slowing of time for an object in motion
that to me is the most fruitful way of
thinking about the relationship of
motion through space and through time
marry them together consider motion
through space-time and then you get the
conclusion that I just described
so captain frantic says is it's sort of
like more you go Easter less you move
north and yes that's exactly the analogy
that we use that I use in elegant
universe and also did visually in fabric
of the cosmos now so if you're moving at
a fixed speed 100 km/h in the northward
direction and your car can only go a
hundred kilometers per hour if you veer
off to the east
then you've diverted some of your
northward motion into eastward motion so
your progress in the northward direction
your speed in the north or direction
will slow similarly if you've got a fix
and unchanging speed through space-time
of the speed of light and if you then
start to move through space your dev are
diverting some of your motion in
space-time into motion through space so
less is available for for your motion
through time and your motion through
time will slow exactly the same thing
with space and time as you suggest
captain frantic with space and space all
right so I think guys I need to I need
to exercise more to be able to do the
full three hours that I did last time
because I'm now with the hour that I did
prior to this session I'm at 3 hours and
8 minutes and I just don't know that I
have the energy left to keep going but
I'm gonna do a few more just for the
heck of it right that was like a false
ending to this session right you all
thought it's all over it's time to go to
sleep but actually I'm gonna do just a
few more my second wind just coming up
alright yeah good keep those questions
rolling do not stop all right sir what
do we have here can dimensions be
relative saintly physics asks in a sense
yes right in terms of the motion through
one can affect the passage through
another with space and time so in that
sense yes but in in any other sense
you'd have to really articulate what you
mean by relative I'm not sure exactly
what you are referring
to quantum jump says can we access the
reddit I think so it was a reddit public
access network it was set up by Random
House so it's the penguin Random House
subreddit or something like that
subreddit called social distancing all
these words don't really mean a whole
lot to me but if you search on to it I
would imagine that you can find it all
right Lauren has a follow up on her
consciousness question what about in
relationship with string theory all
particles are vibrating at specific
frequency could that be occurring in and
out of our brain hence in one mind and
the answer to that again would be I
would say no if string theory is correct
a big F in its own right then yes the
particles in your brain would properly
be described in the language that you
use as vibrating filaments inside your
brain and the interaction of those
vibrating filaments is what generates in
a way that we cannot yet articulate with
any precision whatsoever your conscious
awareness but just because my particles
of my brain are vibrating strings and
just because your particles in your
brain or vibrating strings it doesn't
mean we are one brain it does not mean
we are one thing I like the poetry of
that I like the sensation that you have
in mind that we're all sort of part of
one universal cosmic consciousness that
arises from the vibrating strings of
string theory but it doesn't mean
anything as far as I know it sounds nice
and if it makes you feel good I have no
objection to you thinking about the
world in those terms but my point is if
consciousness is what I think it is and
what many researchers think it is
physical processes taking place inside
of a brain then your brain is one center
of consciousness my brain is another
center of consciousness and they are
separate centers of consciousness they
are not the same they are not one
all right follow-up from last week how
do you re on re re on ORN that's sort of
like in Game of Thrones is not her name
Ariane and I just started watching Game
of Thrones so I'm like years behind but
anyway follow from last week how do you
reach the extra dimensions via equations
but I guess we mean it's how you
describe the actually question also hook
the tofu turned out well last week you
realize that last week when I went home
after our marathon session my son had
been watching this and he held me to
cooking the tofu he said look dad you
mentioned you were gonna cook tofu to
everybody who was watching so I'm gonna
hold you to it and I was so exhausted
but yeah I did I made tofu and black
bean sauce I made one piece of deep
fried tofu for my daughter who does not
like black bean sauce and everything
else oh yes it turned out turned out
quite well so thank you for asking now
to your question in terms of the extra
dimensions how do we describe them with
extra dimensions I'm gonna show you if
that's possible I'm gonna try to bring
my iPad up to what we're looking at here
let's see if it's working so I got to
turn this on a little bit brighter so I
can actually see what I'm doing I have
the the brightness down low so it
doesn't run out of juice because I'm
almost out as it is but let's see
alright so I'm gonna try to do this I'm
gonna try to bring up my my screen so
here is my share my screen is this gonna
work start the broadcast I think it's
gonna work yeah alright alright let's
see three two one come on broadcast and
now if I bring up my notability which
should be somewhere you can see all my
stupid apps where's my notability oh
come on and now it's not scrolling there
it is where's my notability oh damn it
this thing is like it's hiccuping amount
of guys I'm gonna give it one more
second I'm gonna give up come on come on
come on alright my iPad has died on me
guys it's no longer responding so anyway
I'm gonna stop this broadcast darn I
thought it's gonna be all fancy with you
and do my usual iPad split-screen but I
can't get it to work
I think I've shut off that broadcast who
tell me if I have I think I have um so
here's how you do it with with maths X Y
& Z is usually how we mathematically
described the common three dimensions of
experience X gives you a distance this
way Y gives you a distance this way Z
gives you the distance this way how do
we go to higher dimensions we add new
letters X Y Z and W I'm not being
facetious here that W is a coordinate if
it's a fourth independent coordinate it
describes a space that has four
dimensions if I have X Y Z W and T let's
say T is time now I've got four
dimensions of space in one of time if I
want to have 10 dimensions of space and
one of time let me do X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 up
to X 10 and time and by writing down the
equations that govern the geometry the
shape of these dimensions we can have
arbitrarily curved or curled up
dimensions and that's all that we do now
if you ask me can I picture higher
dimensional shapes that I can articulate
using the coordinates and equations I
can't I'll be flat-out honest with you
I've worked on higher dimensional shapes
in string theory for 30 years can I
picture them no can I write down
equations that allow me to analyze them
yes can those equations give me an
understanding on par with visualization
I think they do but if you ask me in my
mind's eye the way I can picture a
basketball and a donut can I picture a
higher dimensional shape no now are
there people who claim that they can
there are so there's a famous story I
don't know if it's true of the
mathematician at Princeton
Thurston teaching a class and I don't
know something like six dimensional
spaces and he describes something to the
class
and he looks at them and they all looked
kind of baffled and he doesn't
understand why they're baffled
so Thurston goes to the corner of the
room to think about how to better
explain these things and he comes back
and says hi know why you are baffled by
my explanation the process I'm talking
about is much more easily visualized in
12 dimensions
you know is that a true story I don't
even know can he really couldn't really
picture things in higher dimensions I
don't know I can't so that's uh that's
my perhaps own limitation all right what
else do we have
Navi Bal asked if our universe is 13.8
billion years old how can astronomers
find starts older than 13.8 billion
years show me those stars show me I
don't know what you're talking about
I'm not aware of stars that are older
than the age of the universe so if you
have evidence for that
send it on look to take a look at it
let's see
Kim Conger asks how do we know that
there are more three spatial dimensions
we don't Kim we don't in the mathematics
of string theory the math as far as you
know seems to require that there are
more than three dimensions of space but
we don't know that the strength is right
I'm a skeptic of string theory I've said
it before I'll say it again and you
should be a skeptic of string theory too
don't believe anything that doesn't have
observational or experimental support
it's an interesting possibility of extra
dimensions it naturally emerges from
string theory we've looked for evidence
for them and we haven't found any yet it
doesn't mean that they're not there it
doesn't mean that we haven't acquired
the data establishing that they are
there so how could we establish them
well look I gave an experiment before
slam the protons together at the heart
Large Hadron Collider and find missing
energy signatures in just the right
pattern that agrees with what we'd
expect if there are extra dimensions
soaking up that energy draining it from
our dimensions that would be really
interesting but we haven't found those
signatures so could we prove or could we
acquire increased evidence beyond pure
mathematics for the existence of extra
dimension sure have we not yet that's
the state of play
a cure to dev why do most physicists
accept the assumption of eleven
dimensions and why not twelve or
thirteen or 26 or ten and blah blah blah
yes so first of all most physicists do
not accept the existence of 10 or 11
dimensions most string theorists allow
for that possibility and work within a
framework that involves those extra
dimensions but we're not saying that
they're there
in the sense that they've been proven
experimentally they've not been proven
experimentally now you might say why do
we look at the particular number of
extra dimensions that we do instead of
13 or other numbers that Kurt to dev
harita lists
that's mathematics so in the mathematics
of string theory there are equations
that tell us the number of dimensions we
don't just make this up we don't just
say hey you know tens nines for Elevens
even better why not 12 or 13
it's mathematical investigations that
lead us to particular numbers of extra
dimensions and those investigations have
not led us to a unique number there are
versions of our mathematics in the old
days that suggested 10 dimensions of
space more refined versions of those
mathematical equations suggest 11
dimensions some insightful physicists
have found reason to allow for the
possibility of 12 in the early days of
string theory when it didn't have so
called fermions only have bosons
the theory suggested that there were 26
space-time dimension 25 of space in one
a time so we have been led to consider a
lot of possibilities for the number of
extra dimensions but as yet there's no
evidence for any of them in the sense of
concrete observations or experiments
it's only mathematics that leads us to
these possibilities so that is the state
of play as of as of now may change all
right
so Joe Siebert asks a follow-up can the
rate in which we age when we're at rest
be considered a maximum speed through
time in the same way that the speed of
light is a maximum speed through space
absolutely absolutely so when I am
looking at you was a Joe sorry the
question just rolled away I think your
name was Joe I'm sorry if it's not so
Joe as I look at you can't really show
you but if I imagine you sitting still
then I can imagine the rate at which you
are aging and I don't mean you know some
very personal biological age I'm talking
about how quickly your clock is ticking
forward in time and that is your
biological aging although people aged
biologically at different rates and
that's not what I'm talking about here
if you then get up and start to walk Joe
I will
if I carefully measure things conclude
that your clock is ticking of time
solver so you're aging slower so yes the
maximum rate at which I will say that
you are aging is when you and I are not
moving relative to each other and if we
are moving relative to each other the
rate of which I will say you are aging
is less than the rate I would have said
when you're stationary so good
excellent conclusion love that we are we
are of one mind of the Lauren I'm
talking poetically I do not think that
we are one mind
literally
okay some more stuff before we wrap it
up what do we got here
Andrew Hanny ass is length contraction a
consequence of the relativity of
simultaneity and you know in some sense
yes so all of the pieces of special
relativity fit together into a very
tight logical pattern and where you
begin and where you end is a matter of
taste and you can begin your thinking
about relativity with the relativity of
simultaneity and recognize that
observers in relative motion will not
agree on what events happen at the same
moment and with that analysis you can
naturally extend it to realize that not
only is it that clocks don't agree but
you can work out the precise discrepancy
between simultaneity aha then you've got
time dilation and once you've got time
dilation then you've got length
contraction because you can measure
lengths with a stopwatch if I want to
measure the length of a train that is
rolling by me I can work out or if I'm
told it's speed relative to me I start
the watch when the front of the train
passes me I stop it when the end of it
passes me I multiply that duration times
the speed and I've got the length of the
train so once you got time dilation in
clocks then length contraction will
follow it because if you're measuring
the length of a train on a clock that I
say is measuring time more slowly than
my own clear you really get a smaller
length and I will because your clock is
ticking time more slowly so I guess is
the answer and you can sort of have the
logical arrows in special relativity
emerge in whatever order you like
the fact is they'll all exhaust the
interesting insights but just through a
different order different way of
thinking through the logical connections
so meirin Chi Kendall asked quakin does
is the block universe compatible with
quantum mechanics
and and it sort of is you know the block
universe you may know guys is this
notion of past present and future all
existing at the same
I can't even frame it same time but I'm
talking about time so but past
presidents you're all existing I don't
even have a time it says no temporal
quality so the past normally we think is
back this way the future that way we're
right here but this whole block of time
in some relativistic sense just exists
is that compatible with quantum
mechanics well yes it is in the sense
that in quantum mechanics the only
difference is we talk about
probabilistic outcomes but if you think
about like the entire wavefunction of
the whole shebang just meandering along
by the Schrodinger equation then in that
notion of reality so the block is a
different kind of block but in that
notion of reality again you can lay out
the whole history of the wavefunction by
just evolving it through Schrodinger's
equation so the block is a little bit
different it's a block of the
probabilistic outcomes at any given
moment in our version of reality but if
you elevate reality to be the domain
where the wavefunction lives and it's
evolving through time then yeah the
blockiness
of that reality is just as blocky
as the classical version focusing upon
positions and velocities of particles
except now we're talking about the
wavefunction and the probabilities that
it describes so in some sense the answer
is yes okay
Prabir dosh has what is the no-hair
theorem well that's the theorem that as
you continue to watch these your daily
equation episodes I will have less and
less hair as the years roll by and the
theorem is that at some point I will
have no hair that is a version of the no
hair
theorem but of course it's not what you
have in mind what you have in mind is
the idea that black holes have no hair
what does that mean that means that
every black hole that has the same mass
charge and angular momentum every such
black hole is identical according to the
classical description of the general
theory of relativity so much as you know
in some sense you know all you know bald
heads look the same all black holes look
the same if they have the same mass
charge in angular momenta there aren't
any distinguishing qualities black holes
don't have hair in the sense of having
local distinguishing qualities that make
once it's black hole different from
another now these ideas were developed a
long time ago and they have been
challenged in very subtle ways where
there are kinds of hair that people now
believe that black holes can support
actually I've been working on this
myself come to think of it I showed
years ago that black holes can have a
certain kind of babka gauge theory a
certain kind of gauge theoretic hair but
it wouldn't be stable in the sense that
if you kick the black hole at all those
singin qualities will radiate the way to
infinity but there have been more subtle
things to do with various unusual
symmetries that are relevant for this
discussion so there is a sense in which
black holes may have a certain kind of
hair even though the old classical
notions of the more coarse kind of hair
have been eliminated through those no
hair theorems so fabulous asked why
don't physicists combine all the physics
equations and formula with general
relativity and see what happens we've
done that and what happens is not nice
the equations all break down the
equations give infinity as their answer
if you just try to naively put quantum
mechanics together with the general
theory of relativity that's why we're
motivated to develop theories like
string theory
theories in which you put gravity and
quantum mechanics together and they
don't yield nonsensical mathematical
results so good idea we've tried it the
most naive way fails more sophisticated
complex ways seem to work
although we've yet to test these ideas
through observation or experiment so
Anand ask is everything predetermined
and again no I'm not saying that
everything is predetermined in the sense
of the actual outcomes that happen even
a single electron the wave function
gives us probabilities for what's going
to happen are those probabilities
predetermined yes in the sense that they
are determined by the mathematical
equation Schrodinger's equation that
just evolves everything forward in time
so if there's nothing else but physics
and I don't think there is anything else
but physics in terms of the fundamental
evolution fundamental change of how the
universe progresses from moment to
moment then it's not that the outcomes
are predetermined but the probabilities
of each possible outcome those are pre
determined so King Lamar says tachyons
travel faster than light what and yeah
you're right is what most people think
the takin's are not real but they are
hypothetical particles that would travel
faster than the speed of light they
would up end notions of causality if we
were playing catch with a tachyon
baseball there would be observers who
would say that you'd receive attacking
on baseball before it threw it to you
that's weird but nevertheless if these
things were real that's what would
happen but most people do not believe
that they are real so bogdan asks what
are your open questions and yeah I mean
open questions that is um that's what
science is all about
I'm sure answering questions is great
but it's the open questions that really
fire us up and I think the deep open
questions are the nature of space and
time you know in in your daily equation
in the series whether you've watched the
previous episodes or not I've said a lot
about space and time I've spoken about
some of the things that people have
asked here today I've spoken about
length contraction have spoken about
time dilation I've spoken about the
curvature of space-time in the general
theory of relativity but the weird thing
is if you said to me yeah you're using
the language of space and time all over
the place but you've never defined it
you never defines face you never define
time and how
- say - you're right I don't really know
how to define them nobody really does we
can speak about their properties and in
that way we refine our understanding of
space and time but I do not know a
fundamental articulation of what spaces
or what time is moreover I don't know if
space and time are fundamental it could
be that space and time are built up of
finer ingredients I like to call them
atoms of space or atoms of time in the
amended earlier and if we could find the
atoms of space or the atoms of time or
even find the right mathematical
language for really talking about them
some of my colleagues in the loop
quantum gravity community believe that
they have the language you're doing so
I'm less convinced of that but one day I
think we will have consensus on the
right language to talk about the
ingredients of space and time and that's
when I think things will take a radical
step forward I think that's where the
big jump in understanding will happen so
that to me is the deep open question
sort of in fundamental science but you
know outside of physics bogged in the
open questions that really fire me up
are what is consciousness like Lauren is
asking what is consciousness I'm giving
you my perspective on what the answer to
that ultimately will look like I think
the answer ultimately will come down to
consciousness is this physical process I
mean like aha I get it that physical
process the motion of those particles in
that particular combination in that
particular choreography that's what it
means to feel this or that emotion
that's what it means to feel this or
that aspiration AHA will begin to
understand it at that deep level I do
think that whatever ten thousand years
from now or whatever is how we will
understand consciousness do I know that
for sure I don't could it be otherwise
possibly so really working out as best
we can the nature of consciousness I
think is again one of those deep open
questions exciting deep open question so
hannah geist marin ellis asks do you
think you have sacrificed many things in
your life would you undo something
looking back well we all have to make
dramatic sacrifices each and every one
of us in different domains that we
experience you know i-i've been blessed
I don't have great hardship in in my
history like everybody else I've
suffered difficult situations you know
the death of a parent is always a
difficult situation and I've gone
through that and that's tough you know
but if I talk about sacrifices I think
most of my sacrifices were sitting in a
library or sitting in my office 10 12
hours a day trying to make progress in
physics and I don't
I didn't view it as a sacrifice at the
time and I don't even know I would
describe it as a sacrifice today but it
definitely definitely was a choice and
it was a choice of not doing something
else and you know now you can bring him
free well it did I freely make that
choice let's put all that to the side it
certainly felt like I was making the
choice freely and I'm gonna use ordinary
language of human discourse even though
you know my view that behind the scenes
I didn't have any choice at all but
using the common language of human
discourse just that we can communicate
one another it was a choice and it was a
choice at the exclusion of other things
and so you look back in your life and
you do wonder what trajectory your life
would have taken had you made different
choices and and made different
sacrifices but I'm I'm I'm I'm thrilled
and happy to have had a life it's not
over yet I hope I've had a life that
focused on questions that really matter
to me you know I look friends of mine
went into Wall Street are really rich
I'm not really rich at all
my son sometimes says me can't you take
a few years off and just go to Wall
Street get really rich it's not my thing
not that I wouldn't like money like
everybody else but the things that
matter to me are these questions I mean
I love talking
about these things and thinking about
the nature of time and space and
relativity and quantum mechanics and
unification and string theory and black
holes and the big banging cyclical
cosmology of that holds any water and I
love those ideas and those ideas to me
make life worth living so there are a
lot of sacrifices to make headway in
this arena to contribute some small
amount to knowledge but I consider them
all worthwhile because in the end of the
day you have a short finite life and you
want to spend your life doing something
that focuses upon things that you feel
matter and to me the ideas and bringing
these ideas to the general public as
we're doing right here to me it feels
like that matters and in the end you
know in your short period of time if you
can say that you did something that you
felt mattered that improved people's
lives in some small way or or brought
joy to people by providing information
in a way that was successful and
exciting and and visually interesting I
can't do the visual side of it other
folks who work with me do all the
visuals out of it then yeah it feels
like it's worth it John prova Titus
asked Percy Greene did you study
solid-state physics during your degree
and did you enjoy it I started a little
solid state physics in a graduate course
in quantum mechanics there was some part
of it that focused on solid state
physics and I guess actually went to
Oxford as a graduate student
we did some solid-state physics I didn't
really enjoy it sorry I mean I didn't
hate it
it just felt more applied than suited my
perspective I am drawn more to the big
questions of like the origin of the
universe that I am - the physics
involved in certain materials and it's
just a matter of taste but I've always
just been fired up by those questions
that to me feel bigger more
philosophical maybe that's a way of
saying it I'd like
physics questions that border on the
philosophical questions because those
are the kinds of questions that we can
think about even without technical
training and get interested in I mean we
can all think about what is time we can
all think about like how would a
universe begin we can all think about
why is there something rather than
nothing I'd like those kind of questions
but we can't all think about you know
the electron band structure and this or
that material you have to have the
technical training to talk about that
and so that's why I think the former
questions are more they grabbed me more
than 10 questions say in solid-state
physics but you know everybody's
different and you have to follow
wherever your passion leads let's see
what else we have here
max have Lobeck ask is there any
possibility that there are also huge
dimensions so huge that we're not able
to see them and and I it is an
interesting question is one that people
ask now and then you know when you say
that something is perhaps curled up so
small that you don't see it then ask
yourself well could it also be so big
that we're not aware of it and when it
comes to dimensions there is a version
of that story that I'll come to in half
a second but the most naive version I
don't see how that works so you know if
I can see along a dimension as long as
it's big enough for me to send light
beams along that direction then
regardless of whether the dimension is
you know a meter or an infinity of
meters it doesn't matter my light will
traverse that dimension and I'll be able
to access it so the most naive version
of dimension being so big that we can't
see it I don't know how to make sense of
that now having said that there is a
version of string theory any was we
discussed before this brane world
scenario I discussed it with slices of
bread I think is the analogy that I used
where we can't see off of our slice of
bread we can't see off of our dimensions
light itself is constrained to our
dimension
and that allows the other dimensions to
be quite large and yet invisible to us
not invisible because they are large per
se but invisible because regardless of
them being large light can't traverse
their expanse so sort of in-between to
what you're asking there can be big
dimensions that in principle we can't
see because what we used to see namely
light is unable to travel in those
directions so so sort of a yes and no on
that um Rob Vandenberg asked where do
you stand on time being a human
construct and I don't know I don't know
part of me feels that the temporal
quality to the world is fundamental but
that's partly because every theory
that's ever been developed has time
within it and the successful ones have
time within it and so we're led to an
intuition that time is within the cosmos
I certainly allow for the possibility
that those atoms of time that I
mentioned a little while ago might be
such that when they're not configured in
the right way there isn't even a notion
of the conventional human construct of
time and that then would of course lead
to the possibility of realms where there
is no time and and and then you then you
ask yourself when those particles are
configured in the right way is that time
woven into the fabric of reality or is
it something that we notice as a pattern
and we impose upon reality in order to
organize perception so it's a very hard
question it's time that we something we
impose on the world in order that we
have some organizational framework for
the events that we observe or is time
fundamentally they're hard to say hard
to say
so Ariane asks about a time machine I
said I've already discussed that earlier
with the wormhole so I won't go back to
that Candice asks Candace will is the
discovery neutrinos linked with the
presence of parallel universes and I
would say no so the existence of
neutrinos does not in any way shape or
form require anything but our universe
and so speculations about other
universes that may come from data
associate with neutrinos is interesting
to kick around but in no way is there
some kind of logical link between
neutrinos and other universes none
whatsoever
Jonathan Salas asks do you think we will
ever reach the technological capacity to
observe strings and well it partly well
largely depends on how big well it
depends on whether shrinker is right so
if string theory is wrong and the answer
is no no matter what our technological
capacity will be we will not observe
strings so they don't exist if string
theory is right then the answer depends
on how big the strings are in the most
conventional formulation of string
theory the strings are the Planck length
it's about 10 to the minus 35 meters
that is so spectacularly small that is
hard to wrap your head around how small
that is an analogy I like to use is that
if you were to take an atom and scale it
up to be as big as the entire observable
universe that's a huge magnification
then under that same magnification the
Planck length or the size of a string in
the commencement formulation would grow
to be roughly the size of a tree so a
string is to an atom as a tree is to the
observable universe that shows how
fantastically small strings are even on
atomic scales and so it's hard to
imagine the technology that would be
able to directly probe such an
incredibly small scale it doesn't mean
they won't exist but
hard to imagine what in the world it
would be now having said that there are
versions of string theory which the
strings are bigger in some versions of
string very much bigger and in any of
those theories proved to be the right
one then yeah it could be that the
observation of strings might be right
around the corner might be within our
lifetime I think that's extremely
unlikely but just to say there are
mathematical versions of string theory
in which they are not as tiny as in the
conventional formulation therefore
Jonathan they would in principle be
susceptible to observation perhaps in
the not-too-distant future that would be
a wonderful development I would not hold
your breath waiting for that to occur
though so Cambridge breaths as an
interesting follow-up question why can't
we predict what is the next thought
that's going to occur inside of our
brain and you need to bear in mind that
when I talk about say the lack of free
will
I don't frame it in terms of my being
able to predict what you're gonna think
next and I don't frame it in that way
for a very good reason the ability for
me to predict what you're going to do
next is logically distinct from my claim
that what you do next will not be the
result of your free will those are two
different statements and the ability for
me to predict your next thought is one
that runs afoul of our basic
understanding of quantum mechanics again
I can't even predict whether the
electron will be here or there
if the wavefunction is the probability
waist is 50 percent chance here 50
percent chance yeah I cannot predict
where it will be and if I can't predict
where a single electron is going to be
based on the insight given to me by the
wavefunction of quantum mechanics then I
can't predict the state of your brain
made up of trillions of particles I
can't do that that's not what quantum
mechanics
allows me to do now even though I can't
predict where your particles will be and
what they'll be doing I can say that
whatever they do will be the outcome of
an evolution described by Schrodinger's
equation not by you you can't get in on
the evolution only the mathematical
articulation is controlling it only
controls probabilities but it still
controls them with ironclad grip and so
whereas I can say with some confidence
that you don't have free will I can't
say with any confidence what you're
gonna do next so in that sense you could
say you're free no one's ever gonna
predict what you're gonna do next but
that's a very modest kind of freedom I
think most of us feel freedom by saying
we are the source of our decisions and
actions not that nobody can predict what
we're going to do that's not enough we
want to feel that we are the ultimate
authors of what we do that's what's
necessary for the usual conventional
notion of free will and that's what I'm
claiming runs into significant tension
with our understanding of fundamental
physics all right a few more before I
will sign off here do astronauts drink
coffee in space ENS I don't know I
though I do know some astronauts I can
ask them if you're really curious I
imagine that they do Harvard grad thank
you for your time and congratulations
Harvard grad did you graduate today
Harvard grad I believe today was
graduation anything else wait here's a
garden says you were free but the
universe already knows what you're going
to do no I'd say it's completely
opposite you're not free and the
universe does not know what you're going
to do so I'd say that comment garden is
maximally wrong I don't mean that it as
an insult I'm just saying it's
completely opposite from what I would
say is the case Claudio Fernandez what
come on ongoing technological endeavors
excite you and how can they influence
physics
well there as you may know is a
wonderful collection of developments in
artificial intelligence editing toward
generalized artificial intelligence and
you know I've spoken to some of the
folks who are leading the charge here
and some of them come from the world of
physics and want to go back to the world
of physics and are working out ways in
which they can turn these artificial
intelligence developments set them to
work on problems and fundamental physics
and how interesting would that be if an
artificially intelligent structure was
able to give us insight into some of the
unsolved questions in physics wow that's
what some of these folks claim is going
to happen in the not-too-distant future
I don't know if it'll put us physicists
us us hopefully intelligent but not
artificially so physicists out of
business but maybe maybe they will that
that would be a that'd be quite
interesting all right let's see what
time is it
Alexandra wants to know what I'm gonna
cook for dinner tonight I'm not gonna
commit to it because as I said my son
may be watching and if he is I don't
want to be locked in I don't have free
choice on a free will in deciding what
I'm gonna what I'm gonna do for dinner
let me just one one or two before we
wrap it up so Georgio's George I Giorgio
a see if only probabilities are
predetermined how can we Square this
with Einsteins block universe again bear
mine Einsteins block universe is a
completely classical description of the
world it's a description of the world
that takes into account relativity but
does not take into account quantum
mechanics and if you want to take
quantum mechanics into account too then
you have to modify the block universe in
my description in terms of probabilities
attempts to do just that Harry Potter
was a harry potter question under that's
coming from maybe you guys can tell me
my you know it's raining here I know if
you can see it it's gonna
for the next day and a half my son wants
me to agree to watch all Harry Potter
movies all eight of them
in the next day and a half while it's
raining outside that make any sense to
you guys I haven't seen any Harry Potter
movies are they good he wants to bring
me into the Harry Potter and universe
before I go somebody tell me whether I
should do that but let me just find a
physics question in the interim
everything's going by so fast
Oh King Umar said light speed is slower
in water then what do you mean by the
speed of light being constant and yeah
when we talk about the speed of light
being constant we mean that it's speed
through empty space through a vacuum as
a fixed number of fixed speed we've long
known that when light goes through a
medium its speed can change because the
medium affects has the light propagates
so you're right the speed of water is
speed of light in water is slower than
the speed of light in a vacuum and but
that doesn't affect anything that we
talked about because the statement more
precisely is the speed of light in a
vacuum is constant quantum jumps asks
from Austin Texas
have you found quantum computing hell
Bodie no Scott Aaronson I dunno Scott
Aaronson very nice guy incredibly smart
guy and quantum computing well I would
say that it has not helping me in any of
the physics that I've done but I full
well imagine that as quantum computing
develops it will maybe it gets blended
with generalized artificial intelligence
to yield a new way of doing physics can
I imagine that I can so yes I do think
that one day now and by the way I should
also say when when you say quantum
computing I took it to mean the actual
devices that people are developing and
building to do quantum computing but
quantum computing as a theoretical
subject has had enormous influence in
extending our understanding of quantum
mechanics so in that sense yes the
people who have spent a lot of time
developing the theoretical architecture
of quantum computing
have advanced our understanding of
quantum mechanics in important ways
let's see what else we got here anything
what time is it now it's 553 so I'll
wrap this up in seven minutes and that
would be our new my new record of four
hours with the the reddit that went
before this let me just see a still test
paratus how smart is Ed Witten goddamn
smart incredibly smart frightening ly
smart you know I worked with him at the
Institute for Advanced Study many years
ago and you know you'd stand in his
office and we'd all be looking at the
same puzzle on the blackboard but Edie
would be like he'd come out with some
insight be like oh my god
where did that come from where did that
where did that insight come from back a
friend of mine spent a summer at the
Institute for Advanced Study in an
office that had a wall adjoining Edward
Witten's wall and they were like the
only two people there most people are
traveling and he described to me how he
was desperately trying to work on his
research projects but all he could hear
through the wall was Edward Witten
typing out one masterpiece paper after
another as if he was hardly needing to
sit down and do the calculations he was
just writing these papers in real time
as these thoughts were gestating in his
miraculous brain so yeah it's probably a
little bit hyperbole there but having
worked with him directly I can tell you
it's a kind of mind that is so rare the
kind of mind that is just so attuned to
the workings of mathematics and the
workings of physics that the insights in
physics are delivered and derived and
arrived at with seemingly no more effort
than breathing whereas for most of us it
is a struggle most of us you sit down
with the equations
and it's a slog to try to find something
new and and an insightful to extract
from the equations but some minds are
just so well structured and organized to
deal with the ingredients in mathematics
and physics that it's just completely
different a completely different process
as far as I can tell and it kind of
makes you wonder is it worth being a
physicist when there are people like
Edward Witten in the world and the
answer is yes because however smart a
given individual is there's just so many
things that they can focus upon and the
wealth of interesting problems in the
world is so enormous that there is a
place for everyone there's a place for
people are going to focus on
observations on experiment even theory
theoretical ideas that are just not the
ones say that are being flattened by the
bulldozer of a mind like an every Witten
so there is there is room there is room
for everybody and that's a that is
ultimately a comforting an important
idea to take on board fully James
Weinberg please comment on the Big
Bounce theory yeah cyclical cosmology it
is gaining more adherence in recent
times due to the work of Paul Steinhardt
and collaborators and it's worth
attention and maybe it's right and only
time will tell so I'm all too thrilled
that alternative cosmological models are
being developed let's see
Brad Dibble says make sure you take your
Louisville straw a slugger when you head
to the house bears don't mind the rain
it is so much it's really interesting
though it's so much lighter than last
week I thought it was dark when I when
we when we ended last week which must
have been around the same times in just
one week it really changes that much
sort of hard to imagine but um but yeah
you're right bears do do like the rain
Rob and uber how often do you have a Q&A
with colleagues
well we always kick around things we
have seminars and questions and answers
all the time
but they're usually focused on very
specific technical issues it's rare that
they brought an out to the range of
things that for instance we speak about
here what else do we have still have two
minutes to go before the witching hour
Dean asks how can any mass exist inside
zero volume inside a black-owned Dean or
not Dean dan D aan den you're absolutely
right that's the puzzle the mass falls
into a black hole it gets crushed
because you can prove that there's no
force that can withstand the pull of
gravity and therefore in in this
environment and therefore the mass gets
ever smaller it gets crushed to an ever
smaller size so you save yourself what
in the world does it mean to have mass
and say zero size is that even possible
and that's what you mean by singularity
it's dividing by zero right the density
is the mass divided by the volume if the
volume is truly in a zero volume space
then then you've got an infinity in
there so that's not exactly right the
Center for black goes more like a moment
in time but it does give you a feel for
the extreme physical environment at the
center of a black hole now it's possible
again it's classical it's possible that
in the quantum description the
singularity gets fuzz out and what was
zero is no longer zero that may be the
way it altom Utley comes about or there
may be a more radical impact of quantum
mechanics as described by folks who have
been developing the fuzzball picture of
black holes but but my point Dan is
you're exactly in the right when you say
what could that mean mass in a zero
volume that's the kind of puzzle that we
face and which drives us onward to try
to make sense of it because it doesn't
make sense as it is articulated John pro
vittatus has a follow-up question in the
last half a minute here thanks for your
earlier answer professor do you believe
someone can be wise without being a
genius like say Albert Einstein
absolutely yes absolutely yes you know
there was
time I'm gonna be honest here I've been
honest the whole time I'm something need
to say that but there was a time when I
kind of thought that the only that the
real geniuses were scientists and that
is such a limited view of of what genius
is genius is so broad and even your
question is a good one
wiseness and an erudition and
insightfulness are qualities that can
exist in minds of radically different
sorts minds that perhaps we wouldn't
characterize as genius whatever that
actually means which is a very broad
broad term and there's so much insight
that we can get from so many different
experiences of the world and that's
really the point there are so many ways
of living in so many lives that have
been led in so many perspectives and so
many personalities and so many different
combinations of experiences inside the
different brains that have lived on
planet Earth that there is so much that
we can get from each of those Minds even
if they're not going to come forward
with an Einstein field equations of the
general theory of relativity they're not
going to come forward with say the the
ninth symphony of Beethoven there's so
much that we can get from the individual
experiences of individual Minds that
have lived on planet Earth that it's a
tragedy when those insights don't find a
way of being brought out to the world so
it's just to say respect and human
kindness and an ultimate interest in the
wealth of experience and wealth of
insights is what we should all have
because it's not all coming from one
mind if Albert Einstein was the only
human who had lived we have an
impoverished world genius aside the
world would be impoverished and the
richness of the world comes from the
richness of human experience broadly
defined
so with that let me wrap things up and
welcome you to again join your daily
equation which will be happening
sporadically going forward but I'm gonna
try to keep these Friday sessions as
long as I can join or subscribe that
button I think it's over there
this subscribe button for world science
festival and again as I mentioned before
in the coming weeks we're gonna have
more of our traditional world Science
Vessel program dominant done in a
non-traditional way which will be fun
some of the programs that we're talking
about a program on cosmology called back
to the beginning I think we're going to
do that we're talking about a program on
quantum entanglement and wormholes which
is basically EPR because er question
that somebody raised here today we're
talking about questions about does math
reveal reality I think we're gonna have
a program on that but talking about
talking about all sorts of things
programming dreaming so so definitely
stay tuned to this channel where those
programs talking with world experts will
be rolling out in the next few weeks and
keep an eye out for your next your daily
equation and join us next Friday for
another marathon session and also you
can join the reddit a 2 p.m. I don't
know if I'm doing next week maybe just a
week after but in any event I'll see you
here next Friday at 3 p.m. I'm now off
with my Louisville Slugger to protect
myself from the Bears I'm off to cook
dinner for the family enjoy your evening
or wherever you are
take care
you